leute habe ich oder grüß gott wieder bayer sagen würde
iq bus abholen easy dark side wolltest du nicht letztens was wegen options und
netz und sowas wissen was du das habe ich das richtige mit der kopf ich habe
sogar ein projekt auf github wo man das sieht wie das einfach funktioniert es
mir eingefallen nach dem letzten stream ich war mal kurz die vm an
das war's du oder ich könnte jetzt in die in den nachrichten historie gucken
aber kannst du einfach mal schreiben ob du das gewesen bist oder nicht
wahrscheinlich ist der inszeniert dann bringe ich durcheinander er wollte
letztens irgendwas wegen options sind dort nicht wissen ganz vergessen keine
ahnung ich kann es ja nachher im stream noch mal ansprechen vielleicht ist ja
derjenige da
so wegen und fick irgendwas mit globaler globalen variablen gefragt denn dort
nicht weiß nicht mehr wer das war ich finde den typ ja cool aber die
fangen mich trotzdem ab mit ihrem gestreike aber wisst ihr wisst ihr dass
der stream indirekt gesponsert ist von der gdl drum dann gespielt ab weil ohne
die gdl hätte ich morgen fünf vor fünf
45 aufstehen müssen um nach frankfurt zu fahren und dank gdl und streit kann ich
auf es machen also ist ich finde das auf twitter immer so lustig wenn ich mir
das angucke so du hast du hast einmal die leute so nach dem motto alter die
streitiger mehr als sie arbeiten wie kann das denn seine bla bla bla so und da gibt es die anderen die sagen die arbeiten wie kann das denn sein bla bla bla und da gibt es die anderen die sagen genau wie kann man überholt werden?
und wie kann das denn sein und da gibt es die anderen die sagen genau wie kann man überholt werden?
So, ja, mein vollste Solidarität und Support und ich hänge da irgendwo dazwischen und denke mir so, ey, ihr dürft das, aber ich finde es trotzdem scheiße.
Und mir geht es am Arsch vorbei, ja? Ey, ich bin immer dafür für vier Tage Woche und verdient mehr Geld, aber eigentlich geht es mir alles am Arsch vorbei.
Ich will einfach nur, dass mich das nicht unnötig in meinem Leben einschränkt.
Das Weshalb und Warum und sonst was ist mir komplett egal. Es soll einfach funktionieren, die Infrastruktur.
Machst du nicht sowieso viel Homeoffice? Doch, aber morgen nicht.
Selfmade Eyes, danke für den Sub.
Doch, wie gesagt, ich mache einen Tag, also ich mache, von meiner vier Tage Woche mache ich drei Tage Homeoffice.
Und einen Tag fahre ich nach Frankfurt und morgen würde ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Aber dank GDL muss ich morgen nicht nach Frankfurt.
Ich habe morgen nämlich, also morgen hätte ich tatsächlich gemusst, oder sagen wir mal so, es wäre schon sehr sinnvoll gewesen,
weil ich habe alle 14 Tage mit meinem Chef so einen Austauschtermin, wie auch immer das, wie nennt sich das offiziell?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Das hat bestimmt irgendeinen coolen Namen.
Wie heißt das? Zeige ich her. Teamskalender morgen.
Okay, das heißt einfach nur Max.
Geil!
Der Termin heißt einfach nur Max.
Na gut, alles klar.
Arzi, dankeschön für den Sub.
Sure fix, ja, genau.
Professor Dr. Ente, Pog Subscriptions, Leute, ja. Massive.
Ups, jetzt gemacht.
Ja, also, deswegen, normalerweise hätte ich morgen 5.45 Uhr aufstehen müssen, als ich rechtzeitig nach Frankfurt komme.
Weil 7.30 Uhr geht es ja, geht es dann los.
Muss ich was machen.
Und das muss ich jetzt dank der GDL nicht.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Updates.
Ist derjenige da, der letztens mich gefragt hat nach globalen Variablen in .NET?
Hört sich nach einem Wind an.
Ja, könnte man so sagen.
Kann man eigentlich, wenn man ein Deutschland-Ticket hat, also ein 49-Euro-Ticket,
kann man das eigentlich anteilig sich erstatten lassen, wenn gestreikt wird?
Du hast doch ein Auto, weißt du?
Doch, doch, das weiß der.
Also gut.
Und ob der das so genau noch weiß, weiß ich, also, der weiß das.
Weil ich hab sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch, aber da war ein anderer dabei.
Da war das noch gar nicht mein Chef, also das hat sich alles ein bisschen geändert.
Ähm, da hab ich das, hab ich den, den Fiat Champ sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch erwähnt.
Weil, weil ich hatte mein GitHub-Account im, im Lebens-, äh, nicht im Lebenslauf, in meinem Skill-Sheet da mit drinne stehen.
Und anscheinend haben die da wirklich geguckt, ja.
Da hab ich auch erzählt, Elektroauto und Integration.
Und so, programmiert.
Doch, doch, die wissen das.
Aber ich fahr kein Auto, außer es muss sein.
Ah, geht schon los.
Ja, Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas habt, was ich mir heute angucken soll, dann schickt rüber.
Ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen schwätzen und dann legen wir los.
KDE Plasma 6 hat ne, ne, ne, ne, ganz ehrlich, ich find alle Oberflächen unter Linux kacke, außer i3.
Und i3 auch nur, weil i3 so minimalistisch ist, dass es einfach nix hat.
Was dir irgendwie auf den Sack gehen kann.
Deutsche Bahn haben Verhältnisse, wenn sie mit ihrem Deutschland-Ticket unterwegs sind und aufgrund einer Verspätung im Nahverkehr mindestens 60 Minuten Verspätung annehmen.
60 Minuten, Alter!
Geil!
Das lohnt sich aber mal richtig.
60 Minuten, Alter.
Meine normale Fahrzeit ist 45 Minuten.
Mobile Flutter-Entwickler.
Eieiei.
Zwove.
Hab ich ja noch nie gehört.
Ja, also ich mag, ich mag i3 als einziges.
Ich mag kein Gnome oder Gnome oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ich mag kein KDE.
Ich mag kein...
Was gibt's da sonst noch?
LXDE, LXQT, Mate oder sonst was.
Weißt du, das kann ich nicht ausprobieren, weil das in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Ja, also ganz im Ernst, wenn's ein Desktop sein muss, dann...
Also Cinnamon, gerade in Verbindung mit Mint, find ich noch ganz erträglich.
Und wenn's irgendwie besonders minimalistisch sein muss, XFCE auch vielleicht noch.
Ja, was auch noch geht, ist sowas wie Fluxbox oder so in der Richtung.
Aber ganz ehrlich, eigentlich find ich alles kacke.
Ich find alles kacke, außer i3.
Und vielleicht, wenn Wayland funktionieren würde...
Wenn Wayland funktionieren würde ordentlich in der VM, dann würde ich vielleicht auch Sway verwenden.
Aber Wayland funktioniert nicht gescheit in der VM.
Aber Plasma...
Plasma 6 ist ganz neu, gell?
Razer, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier heute.
IIQ-Chat wieder am Start, ich seh's schon.
Leute, ich bin ziemlich kaputt.
Ich bin vorhin zweieinhalb Stunden Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich bin jetzt...
So, ihr vorsteht, ich...
Fahrrad kam am Freitag.
Ich bin Freitag Probe gefahren, bisschen über eine Stunde.
Samstag eine Runde gefahren.
Sonntag 7,5 Kilometer gerannt.
Und heute zweieinhalb Stunden gefahren.
Also, ich glaub, ich hab noch nie so viel Sport am Stück gemacht.
Kennt jemand eine gute App, um GPS, also GPX-Routen zu animieren, zu visualisieren?
Also, ihr kennt das doch zum Beispiel, wenn ihr so Tour de France Intro habt, so von der heutigen Etappe,
wo die dann so durchfliegen und man so die Profile der Anstiege sieht und dann schwenkt das so rüber
und dann sieht man, okay, hier ist dieser Wegpunkt.
Dann fliegt das so über eine Map drüber.
Kennt ihr...
Kennt ihr irgendwas?
Irgendeine App, wo man easy aus dem GPX-File, wo man halt seine Tour aufgezeichnet hat, sowas generieren kann?
Ja, einfach schnell googeln kann ich auch.
Am besten für IOS.
Also, am liebsten muss ich da gar nicht an PC für.
Man kann das direkt aus Komoot machen.
Irgendwie öffnen.
Ich fahr nach, also mit dem Fahrrad fahr ich in der Möglichkeit immer was anderes.
Ich mein, gibt auch nur eine beschränkte Anzahl, was man fahren kann.
Leute, heute war ich so im Arsch.
Ich hab bisschen, bisschen verpeilt, ja.
Ich hab Komoot Strecke geplant.
Dacht mir so, ah, okay, passt schon, irgendwie 32 Kilometer, kein Ding.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, da sind vier Berge drinne.
Also Berge, ne, da lachen sich die Schweizer wieder kaputt.
Da sind vier Berge drin und der eine geht bis zu 12% über einen Kilometer.
Ja.
Also, er geht nicht 12% einen Kilometer lang, aber er geht bis zu 12% über einen Kilometer
lang.
Und im Durchschnitt ist er, glaub ich, irgendwie sieben oder so.
Alter, Leute, ich sag euch, ich, ich, ich bin komplett Dettke gewesen.
Weil, ich sag, ohne Schein, sieben Prozent im Durchschnitt ist schon nicht ohne.
Aber mit, mit zwölf Prozent zwischenzeitlich drinne, ey.
Ich, ich hab so geschnauft.
Aber ich, ich bin nicht, also ich musste im Vergleich zum letzten Mal, muss ich nicht absteigen.
Letztes Mal bin ich ja auch einen Berg hochgefahren.
Letzte größere Runde, das wär aber noch ein bisschen länger, da muss ich dann absteigen irgendwann.
Ausruhen, aber das ging.
Es ist aber richtig nice, also man merkt, dass diese Hometrainer-Sache im Winter sich gelohnt hat.
Man, man merkt jetzt, dass man viel mehr Kraft in den Beinen hat.
Wie viel Höhenmeter pro Strecke? Um, um die 400 waren's heute.
Oder? Warte mal.
Warte mal.
Warte mal, kann ich dir sagen.
Äh.
Wo ist denn?
Moment.
Falsches Handy.
Keck, wait.
Äh.
Du.
so vorstellen. Arch, by the way.
Jawoll.
Excellent.
Chat,
letzte Chance, ist derjenige am Start
heute, der mich gefragt hat
gestern zu .NET globale Variablen.
Falls ja, kann ich kurz
was zeigen. Wisst ihr, was mich
heute wieder gestört hat?
Im Wald.
Dass manche Gassigeher es einfach
nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, ihren Hund an die Leine
zu nehmen oder den Hund ans Halsband
zu nehmen, neben sich.
Wenn du dann mit dem Fahrrad vorbeifährst.
Viele Waldwege sind jetzt nicht super breit
und
da hast du immer so ein bisschen mulmiges
Gefühl, dass der Hund jetzt jederzeit
nach dir springen könnte.
Die Herrchen
sind eigentlich immer das Schlimmste.
Hunde können da wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal großartig was für.
Das ist immer echt ätzend.
Zumal ich auf dem Fahrrad meinen Pfefferspray
nicht dabei habe.
Es geht eh so schnell,
da kannst du das nicht zücken.
Claymore! Pfefferspray
Claymore!
Einfach hinsetzen auf den Weg.
So.
Updates sind durch.
Die Stellanzeige für mein Nachfolger
ist live. Nice, schick her.
Oh, kommen wir uns
also je nachdem wie die geschrieben sind, ein bisschen drüber lustig
machen.
Oder aber
was pro Samen
ach nee, pro Samed
was so ein Buchstaben ausmachen
kann, Alter.
Was machen die denn?
Und ich habe noch mal eine Frage an auch die Fahrrad
Enjoyer unter euch.
Vielleicht haben wir da welche.
Was was sagt ihr Kette wachsen oder nicht Kette wachsen?
Das ist keine Anspielung auf irgendwas.
Ich meine das wörtlich.
Was was ist hier mit den BTFS Volumes los?
Chat.
Was?
Schaut ihr euch hier ein ab?
Muss flutschen, denke ich auch.
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Das, was der Hersteller empfiehlt.
Weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt irgendwas empfehlen.
Ich finde die die
Idee dahinter gar nicht, gar nicht mal so, gar nicht mal so blöd,
dass du halt immer komplett fettfreien
Antrieb hast, easy Kette abmachen kannst,
ohne dass du dreckige Hände kriegst.
Einfach mit Wasser das ganze Fahrrad abspülen, ohne dich irgendwie
um Maintenance großartig zu kümmern.
Außer ab und zu mal Kette nachwachsen.
Mal gucken, weil das Ding ist.
Das Ding ist.
Ich werde meine Kassette tauschen und die Kette.
Also ist das schon recht sauber?
Hast du schon Apple Pückel angeguckt?
Nein, das ist das ist das Apple Jason, oder?
Das ist habe ich mal in irgendeinem News gelesen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es wirklich Jason Konkurrent überhaupt ist.
Ja, nee, habe ich, aber habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Oh Mann.
Ja, also ich habe heute echt wieder gemerkt.
Als ich dann den.
Zwölf die zwölf Prozent Steigung hoch bin,
dass ich doch noch ein bisschen mehr.
Wie nennt man das?
Bandbreite auch was meine Schaltung angeht,
weil es ist echt schon da kriege ich noch nicht genug Watt aus den Beinen raus,
dass ich das easy da hochfahren kann.
Ja, es ist eigentlich.
Ich habe mich da ein bisschen schlau gemacht.
Es ist eigentlich relativ easy.
Man muss einmal alles schön entfetten.
Nein, jetzt.
Mittlerweile habe ich zwei vorne.
Das alte hatte nur eins.
Aber ich habe eine elektronische Schaltung mit Synchro Schiff.
Das ist mega nice.
Ich schalte auch nur hoch und runter und das Umwerfen vorne macht er automatisch Synchro Schiff.
Ja, das heißt so.
Okay, die I2 Synchro Schiff.
Ja, so funzt das.
Es gibt sogar.
Es gibt sogar eine App für das ist.
Das ist aber echt.
Das ist wirklich dann die Wissenschaft für sich.
Das klingt was aus Yu-Gi-Oh!
Ja, stimmt schon.
Musst du erst mal opfern.
Das ist dann echt die Wissenschaft für sich.
An sich ist das ist das mega nice.
Du musst dich gar nicht mehr darum kümmern, dass vorne geschaltet wird.
Ja, also an sich ist einfach.
Man muss alles entfetten.
Und dann ein bisschen Wachs drauf tröpfeln.
Was eine Wissenschaft für sich ist.
Ist heiß wachsen.
Mit mit Herdplatte und Tabs und allem.
Das ist mir dann aber auch fast schon zu viel.
Das gut.
Trinkst du Sportshakes?
Nein, ich trinke außer Wasser und Tee nichts.
Ich trinke keine Fanta, keine Cola.
Oder oder irgendwie Kaffee oder so.
Ich trinke nur Wasser und Tee.
Ich ich fresse genug.
Ich habe mehr als genug.
Ja, Zeug zum Muskelaufbau.
Kein Kaffee.
Nee, das ist jetzt doppelt fail.
Eigentlich mit kein Kaffee.
Weil ich bin gefühlt der einzige Altiler, der kein Kaffee trinkt.
Und bei den ganzen Fahrradfahrern ist Kaffee auch so eine Religion.
Ich bin jetzt doppelt weird champ.
Zumindest war ich heute froh, dass ich was zu trinken dabei hatte.
So, dann legen wir mal los.
Du trinkst auch kein Kaffee.
Wir sind nicht allein.
Es gibt noch genug.
Das mache ich nicht.
Es gab Spinat Nudeln.
Was gab's bei dir?
Super gesunde Sachen gab's bei dir.
Super gesunde Sachen gab's bei mir heute.
Äh, Pommes Frites, Mozzarella Sticks mit Mayonnaise dabei.
Gesündestes Essen überhaupt.
Also ich bin, ich werde dieses Jahr 40 und ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht mit Kaffee angefangen.
Mozzarella Sticks, das ist so paniert.
Von dem Mozzarella schmeckst du eh nix.
Nee, nee, nee, das, wobei das stimmt auch nicht.
Mozzarella Sticks, da ist so eine komische Dipsoße dabei.
Aber, aber Mayonnaise für die, für die Pommes Frites.
4K, 4K OLED, 240 Hertz, 31,5.
Also außer, dass ich mir ein 31,5 Zoll bei meinem Sitzabstand viel zu groß wäre.
Der Rest ist natürlich extremly nice.
Hat er auch einen Lüfter?
Oder kommt er ohne Lüfter aus?
Ja, ist aber so.
Ich trink nur Wasser und Tee.
So.
Ja, dann fangen wir doch mal an, würde ich sagen.
Erstmal husten.
So.
Dann hustchamp.
Eine, eine Runde Astriquarium zur Entspannung, bevor es losgeht.
So.
Also mit was fangen wir an?
Ich würde sagen, ProSamed.
Das müssen wir hier aber mal ganz schnell rüberpasten, weil eindeutig zu hell.
Okay.
ProSamed.
Ich muss erst mal gucken, was das ist.
Not now.
Wir sind ein operatives Netzwerk für Gesundheit.
Wir stehen für eine ganzheitliche Versorgung aus...
Das ist quasi so eine Art Apotheke oder sowas?
Ja.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Okay, Berlin.
Da sind die eh schon mal lost, ey.
Aha.
Okay.
Also, was wollen sie denn haben?
Die suchen einen IT-Administrator.
Nein, nein, nein.
Einen IT-System-Administrator suchen sie.
Einen permanent Employee.
Fulltime in Berlin.
Aha.
Also eine Festanstellung sozusagen.
Instant Berlin Flame.
Ich war nur einmal in meinem Leben in Berlin.
Ich muss gerade überlegen, ob das stimmt.
Ähm...
Und...
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ich habe keine...
Keine...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Kein Verlangen, da wieder hinzugehen, ne?
Da fand ich München tatsächlich nicer.
Wenn sie mich da auch nicht wirklich hinzieht wieder.
Du wechselst von Leipzig nach Berlin.
Ja, jeder worauf er Bock hat, ne?
München ist sehr nice.
Vor allem ist München, glaube ich, sehr nice.
Teuer.
Hamburg war ich tatsächlich schon öfter.
Hamburg hab ich mal...
Das erste Mal, wo ich in Hamburg war, hab ich ein MMO-Grill besucht.
Frag mich nicht.
2004 oder so.
Das lief aber nicht so gut.
Das erste Mal in Hamburg.
Naja.
So, also.
Was wollen sie denn haben?
war die schwer zu sagen also es war super weird also wenn man sich nur
online kennt und ein paar mal telefoniert hatten sich rl sieht da
merkt man meistens relativ schnell ob man sich so gegenseitig als findet oder
nicht und wir fanden uns gegenseitig nicht so
nice pech gehabt der euro child 26 box abscription es kam kein vibe auf das
trifft es eigentlich ziemlich gut wisst ihr manchmal manchmal sind jugendworte
doch sehr nice ja es ist ein unterschied ob man sich aus dem game kennt und
bisschen telefoniert auch weiß wie die anderen aussehen und so aber wenn man
sich dann wie live trifft es ist ein unterschied es kam kein vibe auf das
trifft es wirklich gut ja ich bin am gleichen tag auch wieder heim gefahren
ich bin am gleichen tag auch wieder heim gefahren
ich bin am gleichen tag auch wieder heim gefahren dann bin ich dann bin ich mitten
dann bin ich dann bin ich mitten
dann bin ich dann bin ich mitten in der nacht angekommen am bahnhof und
in der nacht angekommen am bahnhof und
in der nacht angekommen am bahnhof und dann ist kein bus mehr gefahren damals
dann ist kein bus mehr gefahren damals
dann ist kein bus mehr gefahren damals hatte man noch kein handy kein
hatte man noch kein handy kein smartphone um etwas nach zu
smartphone um etwas nach zu
smartphone um etwas nach zu nachzugucken nach vom hauptbahnhof bin
nachzugucken nach vom hauptbahnhof bin
nachzugucken nach vom hauptbahnhof bin ich heim gelaufen mit einer nacht hat
ich heim gelaufen mit einer nacht hat
ich heim gelaufen mit einer nacht hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt
sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt
Ansonsten suche ich nachher bei den üblichen Verdächtigen
Nochmal ein bisschen was
Was mich ansprechen soll
Ich suche keinen Job
Gibt es die Story schon in voller Länge
Im Archiv Max
Ne ich glaube nicht
Aber viel mehr gibt es dazu auch nicht zu erzählen
Oder wahrscheinlich habe ich das auch schon mal kurz
Aber viel mehr gibt es da echt nicht zu erzählen
Das einzige was ich noch weiß ist
Dass sie Kim hieß
Und blonde kurze Haare hatte
Ansonsten
Ein Piercing in der Nase hatte sie
Das kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern
Dunkel
Aber ansonsten ich habe keine Ahnung mehr
Wie die ausgeschaut hat
Kein Plan
Kim.com
Genau
Steinhadler 5 Tage vor den Zaff
Aber ansonsten
Keine Ahnung mehr
Ich weiß noch nicht mal was sie in dem Game
Gespielt hat überhaupt
Das war bestimmt
Er
Das sah dem
Dann hat er sich aber stark gewandelt
Seitdem
Keine Ahnung
Ich weiß da kaum noch was von
Ich meine das war 2004 oder so
Das ist schon ewig her
Ja sind wir
Hot Cheesecake
Ansonsten weiß ich da echt gar nichts mehr
Aber es kam eh kein Vibe auf
Wie ihr schon festgestellt habt
Ja Erot Child schickt rüber
Wenn ich mir was angucken soll
Kann sein dass ich irgendwas übersehen habe
Aber ich glaube
Ich glaube nicht dass ich irgendwas übersehen habe
Also gucken wir uns jetzt hier
ProSamed an
Also wir bieten
Okay was ich schon mal gut finde
An der Stellenanzeige
Sie fangen nicht an mit
Wir sind führender Dienstleister
Im Bereich XY
Allerdings muss ich ehrlich sagen
Vielleicht
Sagen wir mal so
Ein Satz
Zu der Firma könnte man vielleicht schreiben
Ich weiß nicht jeder wer ProSamed ist
Aber finde ich schon mal gut
Das nicht erst irgendwie ein halber Roman
Selbstbeweihräucherung kommt
Okay
Gehaltsentwicklung und Rahmenbedingungen
Entsprechend Apotheken Tarifvertrag
Da weiß ich nicht ob das gut oder schlecht ist
Tarifvertrag ist prinzipiell eigentlich immer ganz gut
Ob das
Ob der was taugt
Und welche Stufe man in diesem Tarifvertrag bekommt
Da gibt es ja sicherlich auch unterschiedlich
Was ist das für eine Webseite
Alter
Oder liegt das an meinem Darkreader
Nee das ist ein Darkreader
Das ist ein Darkreader
Nee das liegt noch nicht an meinem Darkreader
Die Seite ist einfach broken as fuck
Das kann man nicht mal markieren
Die brauchen ganz dringend einen Anwendungsentwickler
Da fuck
Okay
Die Webseite ist wirklich kacke
Zumal du es jetzt nicht mal anklicken kannst
Du kannst ja nichts
Als PDF exportieren kannst
Okay
Aber ist nicht so sehr
Garmin
So also lass mal hier angucken
Äh Apotheken Tarifvertrag
Okay das
Kommt auf die Stufe an
Aber erste mal ist Tarifvertrag nicht verkehrt
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge
Arbeitgeberanteil plus 20%
Auf die Eigenumwandlung
Ist immer nice wenn sowas angeboten wird
Das ist auch ein bisschen wenig
Monatlicher Sachgutschein
Im Wert von 50 Euro
Netto
Bezahlt ein ordentliches Gehalt
Dann erübt sich das Problem
Elektronische Arbeitszeiterfassung
Moment das ist eine wir bieten?
Jede Minute zählt und kann abgebummelt oder ausgezahlt werden
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das so ein Vorteil ist
Aber Zeit der Fassung ist doch sogar Pflicht mittlerweile
Also das ist das ist ja okay nice
Aber ist das jetzt so ein krasser Vorteil was man unter wir bieten
Okay viele Möglichkeit der beruflichen Weiterbildung
Okay Mitarbeiterrabatte in unseren Apotheken
Ja gut wenn man das braucht
Ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt
Ein individuelles Einarbeitungskonzept ohne Zeitdruck mit Platzabgaben
im ureigensten Interesse der Firma, dich
einzuarbeiten, dass du was machen kannst für dein Geld.
Ja, auch wenn es
witzigerweise bei vielen nicht funktioniert.
Aber eigentlich
sollte das das ureigenste Interesse
der Firma sein, die neuen Leute ordentlich
einzuarbeiten. Bunte Teams,
kompetent, gut
eingespielt und durch Zusammenhalt
geprägt. Weird
Champ.
Zentrale Lage,
Nähe S-Bahn. Okay, das ist natürlich gut.
Wenn man
eine gute Anbindung hat und wenn es Parkmöglichkeiten
gibt, das ist tatsächlich ein Vorteil.
Ein familienfreundliches Umfeld
inklusive Kinderspielzimmer mit Elternarbeitsplatz.
Für Leute, die sowas
brauchen, ist das sicherlich
sehr nice. Bei mir
auf der Arbeit gibt es auch einen Kindergarten.
Wöchentlicher Rückenkurs.
Pilates und Massagen
vor Ort zu vergünstigten Konditionen.
Why not?
Es gibt einen ganzen Kindergarten, ja.
Wir sind eine riesen Versicherung in
Frankfurt. Wir haben, frag mich nicht,
wie viele tausend
Mitarbeiter oder so. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel wir
insgesamt haben.
Da gibt es genug Leute mit Kindern und die finden
das mega, dass wir einen eigenen Kindergarten haben.
Regelmäßige Events.
Zum Beispiel Sommerfest mit Barbecue, große
Weihnachtsfeier oder Teamessen.
Ja, ist für mich schon mal kein Vorteil.
Ist für mich eher nervig.
Sucht nach einer Versicherung in Frankfurt mit Kindergarten.
Let's go. Das Mitwirken
in einem, ich glaube da steht es aber,
sucht, wenn ihr wollt.
Das Mitwirken in einem
inhabergeführten Familienunternehmen
mit liebenswerten Traditionen und einem wertschätzenden
Klima. Ja, wie toll
das ist, zeigt sich erst, wenn man da ist.
Bitte beachten Sie, dass
wir nur Kandidatinnen in unserem Auswahlverfahren
sind, die bereits eine Arbeitserlaubnis
besitzen. Gut, das ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Aufgaben und Tätigkeiten.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Im Herzen, ach jetzt,
jetzt kommt die Einleitung,
wer Sie sind. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
falsch rum.
Okay, im Herzen Berlins versorgt
das ProSame-Netzwerk für
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Das überdurchschnittliche
Wachstum
des Netzwerks wird begleitet von
einer kontinuierlichen Anpassung der EDV
Infrastruktur und Prozesse.
Zur Unterstützung der damit verbundenen
Projekte suchen wir zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt
einen Systemadministrator MWD,
der Lust auf diese Reise hat.
Aber Hauptsache EDV.
Sie sorgen dafür,
dass die Netzwerkinfrastruktur
stabil ist und läuft.
Sucht ihr nicht eher einen Netzwerkadministrator
dann?
Systemadministrator ist für mich
jetzt zwar auch durchaus Netzwerk,
aber nicht hauptsächlich Netzwerk.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Die Anwender
in den Fachabteilungen sind happy,
weil sie ihn im Rahmen eines First Level
Supports bei Frank...
Jetzt ist vorbei
bei mir. Keck bei.
Da hätte ich
ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Sie kümmern sich um die Administration
und bieten Second Level Support im Bereich
der Serversysteme und Firmennetzwerke.
Ja Moment jetzt. Ja was denn jetzt?
Okay, du machst
Endanwender Support, Hilfe mein Drucker
funktioniert nicht.
Und dann musst du dich natürlich auch noch
mit Servern und
Netzwerken und so gut auskennen, dass du den Rest machen kannst.
Okay, okay.
Du machst einfach
Full Stack Administrator.
Du machst alles.
Sie meistern Installation,
Konfiguration, Optimierung, Monitoring,
Patchmanagement, Troubleshooting
von Windows
beziehungsweise...
Was soll beziehungsweise
an der Stelle heißen?
Es sind Windows und
Linux Server. Beziehungsweise.
In virtuellen Umgebungen.
VMware, vSphere.
Das kann man nicht ohne, ja.
Sie bringen sich aktiv in Projekte
zur Konzeption und Optimierung
der IT-Infrastruktur für die
Steuerung und Koordination externer Dienstleister ein.
Was?
Sie bringen sich aktiv in Projekte zur Optimierung
der IT-Infrastruktur für die Steuerung
Also
die haben beispielsweise irgendeinen
Provider, der für sie die Internetanbindung macht
und haben vielleicht irgendeinen, der die Webseite
betreut oder was auch immer und die sollst du dann
quasi noch
ordentlich
einplanen oder wie?
Durch ihre Teilnahme
an der Rufbereitschaft
sichern sie sich kontinuierlichen
Assetbetrieb
Wait a minute
Vielleicht sollten wir mal
umgedreht fragen
Was machst du eigentlich nicht?
Du machst
First Level End Anwender Support
Du machst Netzwerk, Server
Virtualisierung
Monitoring
Projekte
und
du koordinierst irgendwelche externen Dienstleister
und du machst die Rufbereitschaft dafür
Eigentlich gibt es nichts
was du nicht machst, oder?
Also was zu diesem
was dazu gehört, ich mein
Du machst jetzt nicht
die Tür morgens auf und zu
am Haupteinkommen, wobei man weiß es ja nicht
Also und dann auch nur 28 Tage
Urlaub?
Also das scheint mir doch wieder, wir suchen eine IT-Abteilung
in einer Person zu sein
Ich muss aber nochmal dazu sagen
Stellanzeigen sind immer den
ersten Eindruck, den wir bekommen
von einem Unternehmen
Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass der Laden wirklich schlecht ist
oder so
Aber wir können das ja nur anhand der Stellanzeige beurteilen
Genauso wie die das nur anhand unserer
Bewerbung
und was wir da so reinschreiben
und das aber dem ersten Kontakt mit uns beurteilen können
und das ja auch machen
Und so müssen wir das mit der Stellanzeige
auch handhaben, also es kann sein, dass der Laden
wirklich gut ist und was taugt
Für mich sieht die Stellanzeige allerdings nicht so aus
als würde ich da arbeiten wollen
Aber sieht auch nicht so aus
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass der Laden
noch schlimmer ist, als man denkt
Ja es ist nichts, ist da ausgeschlossen
Kompetenzen und Talente
Ok es geht noch weiter
Abgeschlossen, ok das übliche, Physi, Ausbildung
Mindestens 3 Jahre aktive Berufserfahrung
Wünschenswerte Kenntnisse
Mikrofokus Open Enterprise Server 24
Ok
Was ist
Mikrofokus Open
Der Name klingt schon so Business Enterprise
dass ich...
ganz, ganz harte Business Enterprise Software
Da hätte ich ja
hätte ich ja wenig Bock
What?
Mikrofokus Groupwise Workgroup Suite
Was es nicht alles gibt
Mann
Da findste genau das
Das ist quasi Outlook nur nicht Outlook oder was?
Alter das sieht aus wie 1995
Haha
Sieht das schlecht aus
Ich weiß jetzt schon wo ich definitiv keinen Bock habe
damit zu arbeiten
Zenworks Configuration Management
Ich dachte das ist so eine Helpdesk Software
Ich wusste gar nicht
dass die auch sowas haben
Die haben aber auch super exo...
Ach Moment das ist auch Mikrofokus
Die haben auch super exotisches Zeug am Start oder?
Novell
Alter was für Oldschool Shit ist hier am Start
Das ist ein Name
Den hab ich schon die letzten...
Seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr gehört
Ach ich hab das übrigens verwechselt mit
Zendesk
Zendesk ist die Ticketsystem
Virtualisierungslösung
Unter
VMware ESX
Moment
VMware ESX ist die Virtualisierungslösung
Windows Server 2012
2016, 2022
Windows 10, Windows 11
CEO
infra
Was
Ja, WSL hat nicht so gut funktioniert
unter Windows Server, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Das stört Windows komplett.
Ja.
Naja, habe ich aus Versehen
an Windows gelöscht halt.
War auch, gab
Schlimmeres. Da ist es wenigstens weg.
Okay.
Suse Linux Enterprise, Ubuntu Server,
CentOS. CentOS benutzt keiner mehr.
Es sei denn, sie haben noch
CentOS 7.
Und das sollte man jetzt schleunigst loswerden.
Radiant Tracer, danke schön für den Sub.
So, ich muss mal kurz gucken, nicht, dass ich
wieder irgendwas vergessen habe hier.
Stream Manager.
Steinadler hat auch
subscribt. Dankeschön.
Bin ich sicher, ob ich es übersehen
habe. Oder bin mir auch nicht
sicher, ob ich es gesehen habe.
Also.
Vernetzungsstrukturen
via
VPN. Das sind aber besonders
Deutsch-Enjoyer, oder?
Vernetzungsstrukturen via VPN.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, ne?
Mindestens C1
Deutschkenntnisse, offene Augen und Ohren
für Nutzerbedürfnisse und die Fähigkeit,
Sachverhalte zu erfassen und Lösungen zu erarbeiten.
Ausgeprägte Dienstleistungs-
und Kundenorientierung.
Engagiertes Auftreten
sowie Verantwortungsbewusstsein.
Das kommt alles mit der passenden
Bezahlung.
Analytisches und planerisches,
Denken, Selbstständigkeit beim Erkennen
und Lösung von IT-Problemen.
Führerschein Klasse B. Wünschenswert.
Wann kann es losgehen?
Zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt. Interesse.
Unten klicken.
Expected Salary.
Oh, wie viele Genders gibt es denn zur Auswahl?
Undefined.
Schwer einzuschätzen.
Ob die taugen oder nicht?
Wir gucken uns jetzt die an.
Weil mich die Webseite
schon so fertig macht, wenn ich mir die angucke.
Also.
Die brauchen dringend
einen Webdesigner.
Das sieht grausam aus.
Und das liegt nicht an meinem Darkreader.
Die Webseite sieht normalerweise auch so kaputt aus.
Deutsch C1 muss man in Berlin
schon erwähnen. Da könntest du recht haben.
Ich weiß nicht, was C1 bedeutet.
Ich kenne das.
Es gibt da so verschiedene Stufen.
Das steht auch bei Englisch auch immer.
Vielleicht liegt es am Browser.
Meinst du?
Meinst du, es sind Codes?
Chrome? Chrome?
Ne, ist auch nicht besser.
Guck mal, wie es in Firefox aussieht.
Da würden sie ja bei mir Pluspunkte sammeln.
Ne, Firefox ist auch kaputt.
Was steht denn auf dem Logo?
Äh, das sind Einsen und Nullen hier.
Wir sind...
Dienstplan?
Steht da?
Steht da, wir sind Dienstplan?
Wir sind Dienstplan-Lan.
Warum ist das Logo übernimmt?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Warum kann man den Text nicht markieren?
Warum kann man nicht rechtsklicken auf der Seite?
Was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Webseite, Mann?
Wir akzeptieren jetzt die Cookies.
Okay, wir sind Dienstplan.
Ah, die bieten irgendeine Zeiterfassungssoftware oder so an.
Also...
Ich mache jetzt mal den Dark wieder aus, ja.
So sieht die Webseite ja gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Coole Animationen haben sie am Start.
Also...
Cool.
Man hat es versucht. Schön ist sie nicht.
Produkte.
Ja, die bieten Zeiterfassungssoftware an.
Die ein bisschen auch...
Die ein bisschen aussieht wie...
So olle...
Alter!
The fuck!
Das sind Dings, das sind GTK.
Die alten GTK-Icons.
Das ist ne...
Sag mal, ist das ne olle Windows-Forms-Anwendung?
Die sieht schon richtig oldschool aus.
Wer kauft sich denn freiwillig sowas, Mann?
Das sieht aus
straight 1998.
Dass es nicht webbasiert ist,
sondern ne Windows-Client braucht,
um so was rauszuhaben.
Es geht einfach mal ein Video los,
weil du auf der Seite runterscrollst, Mann.
Was ist das für ne Webseite, Mann?
Weiß ich nicht, da ging eben einfach...
Hier.
Guck mal.
Noch nicht mal richtig skaliert ist das Ding auf dem Handy, Alter.
Das ist nicht mal richtig skaliert auf dem Handy.
Das ist nicht...
Das haben die auf dem Desktop aufgenommen
und wahrscheinlich nachbearbeitet
auf so ein Handy gemacht.
Boah, das...
Es kann sein, dass die Firma super ist,
aber das wirkt echt ein bisschen
gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Wie ist denn der Dienstplan?
Was kostet denn der Kram so?
Achso, darf man nicht sehen.
Ja gut.
Alter!
Alter, die Webseite, die macht mich fertig!
Und was kostet's?
Weiß man nicht.
Gibt's erst,
nachdem dir das
das Sales-Team
drei Stunden das Ohr abgekaut hat,
erfährst du, was es kostet.
Okay, drei Votes.
Drei Votes, das ist jetzt nicht aussagekräftig.
Das ist irgendeiner,
der abgefuckt ist
und dann schlecht...
Also, drei sind echt ein bisschen...
Okay, es war Azubi.
Ziemlich alles von uralter Hardware bis zur Räumlichkeit ist alles dabei.
Ich hab meine Ausbildung dort abgebrochen.
Oh, Mann.
Ja, aber das ist nicht so wirklich aussagekräftig.
Äh, wait a minute.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich die L-Anzeige angucken.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt Dark Reader wieder an.
Okay, die Software wirkt schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig, so.
Aber es sagt nichts über den Laden.
Also der Laden kann tatsächlich nicht schlecht sein.
Wir hatten das gepostet vorhin.
War ne Frage.
Wir hatten das vorhin gepostet.
TDA.
Du musst...
Okay.
Das war das falsche, was ich hatte.
Nee, das sind die schon.
Wir hatten das gepostet eben vorhin.
Weil mich würde jetzt halt interessieren,
derjenige, der das gepostet hat,
arbeitest du da oder wolltest du dich da bewerben?
Weil da könntest du uns ja mal sagen,
ob das...
dass es vielleicht gar nicht so schlimm ist,
wie es so aussieht.
Kennst du einen guten Cloud-Provider
a la Hetznall, wo in Norwegen...
Hetznall ist nur in Finnland.
Da geht's ja eigentlich drum.
Das zeichnet sie aus.
Du verfügst wieder ein abgeschlossenes...
Okay, die übliche Sache.
Man kann's ja nicht markieren.
Du bist fit am Telefon und kannst sowohl interne Anwender
als auch externe Kunden beraten und betreuen.
Oh MonkaS,
da geht's schon los, Alter.
Welche Zeiterfassung läuft bei euch?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
was da im Hintergrund läuft.
Nix worüber...
Zumindest nix.
Worum ich mich kümmern muss.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Du bist kreativ in Entwicklung, Realisierung,
neuartige IT-Softwarelösungen.
Ja, vielleicht welche,
die auf dem Handy gescheit skalieren.
Erfahrene deutsche und gute Englischkenntnisse
runden dein Profil ab.
Zuständige Hauptaufgaben,
ihre berufliche Zukunft.
Freu dich auf ein interessant...
Moment, das ist alles?
Was ist das für eine Stellenanzeige, Mann?
Da ist ja nichts.
Da steht weder, was die eigentlich genau entwickeln,
noch was, was sie an der Stelle tun.
Was?
Okay, das macht keinen Sinn.
Kann man Links posten?
Klar, immer her damit!
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwas übersehen hab.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Ja, schick her.
Wir haben Zeit.
Wie schaut's damit aus?
Kann man gleich gucken.
Modulat.
Also, das fällt bei mir durch.
Sowohl nach kurzem Googlen,
als auch die Webseite, als auch die Stellenanzeige.
Das ist wirklich...
echt fragwürdig.
Was hältst du davon,
was bewerbungsmanagement.net
ist das für eine...
Wie viele von diesen Seiten gibt es da eigentlich?
Also, falls
derjenige tatsächlich dort arbeitet,
und sich dann...
Ich weiß ja nicht mehr, wer es gewesen ist.
Falls derjenige dort wirklich arbeitet...
Also,
unabhängig von der Webseite, sowas ist egal.
Also, dass sich da seit 2021
keiner drauf beworben hat,
finde ich verständlich.
Da steht nichts drin.
Also, es steht weder drinne,
was mich jetzt persönlich ansprechen würde,
dass ich da hingehe,
noch irgendwas von Substanz,
was denn eigentlich gesucht ist.
Anwendungsentwickler, Frontend, Backend,
irgendwelche Automatisierungssachen,
welche Technologie als Basis,
was wird eingesetzt...
Das ist komplett nichtssagend.
Ausbeutung pur, sagst du.
Ja gut, das sagt der Chat.
Das kann ich natürlich nicht beurteilen.
Keine Benefits.
Letzter Versuch für die Rezension, was?
TDAHR, was?
Gräfenbräuch?
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Google Rezession soll ich gucken, okay.
Äh...
Google?
Hä, warum ist es jetzt auf einmal auf Englisch?
Alter, Google ist schon...
Alter, wie schaffen die es bei Google
eigentlich so eine simple Sache
wie einen More-Knopf zu verkacken?
So schwer kann es doch nicht sein.
Ruf drücken, dann klappt mehr aus.
Yonder Boy, den brauchen wir jetzt.
Ja, genau.
Der kennt sich aus.
War der nicht bei...
Bei AWS?
Wer ist da...
Abkontiv schlecht.
Gute Wandermöglichkeiten.
Ja, also das liest sich
wirklich nicht nach einem
Arbeitgeber, wo man hin will.
Hast du deine Stellenanzeige schon abgecheckt?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welche deine
gewesen ist, aber ich habe hier...
Einige, einige offen.
Welche war deine?
Ach, heute habe ich schon wieder eine andere Postleitzahl.
Amazon ist auch am Jibäden.
Muss mal ein bisschen was zumachen, hier wird zu viel.
Ähm...
Hand?
Hab ich nicht.
Sehe ich hier nicht.
Welche das...
Welche davon deine ist?
Ich habe glaube ich alle aufgemacht, die Leute.
Ja...
Naja.
Das ist doch History, nichts mehr.
Okay, was haben wir denn als nächstes
Schönes?
Endor AG.
Spitzenleistung
seit über 20 Jahren.
Ähm...
Und wo steht, was es da gibt?
Moment. Fanatec?
Sind das nicht die mit dem Headshot-Controller?
Doch, das sind die!
Shit!
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will,
braucht eine top Ausstattung.
Und da ist der Fanatec Headshot-Controller
genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einer ultrapräzisen
Gamermaus und einem Highspeed-Pad.
Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Die Maus ist super ergonomisch
und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen Gamer-Sessions
für ermüdungsfreies Spielen.
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein
5-Wege-Steuerrad sorgen dafür,
dass sie ihre Spielfigur auch in heißen
Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasma-Glide-Maus-Füße sorgen zusammen
mit dem Highspeed-Pad für minimale
Haft- und Gleitreibung,
für schnelles, präzises Zielen im Spiel.
Das leichte Kabel
kommt ihnen dabei garantiert
nicht in die Quere.
Dafür sorgt die clevere Kabelführung.
Das sieht aus wie so eine Diebstahl-Sicherung
im Baumarkt.
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen
Farben, Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz
machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
Profigamer sind begeistert
von den Programmiermöglichkeiten
für Maus und Tastatur.
Auch Makros lassen sich
problemlos einsetzen.
Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen,
Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der Fanatic Headshot Controller
ist das ultimative Set
für Gamer.
Und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk
gut ankommt? Probieren sie es aus.
Okay, die gibt's
anscheinend wirklich noch.
Und die machen eventuell
heute anderes und besseres Zeug
als damals.
Ähm, wo sind denn
die Stellenanzeigen jetzt überhaupt?
Aktuelle Jobs? Heu, so viel!
IT-Administrator.
Guck mal, sogar eine
Physieausbildung 2025.
Ein Last Mile
Expert.
Was meinen die denn damit?
Internetprovider
Anschlusskram? Netzwerkanschlusskram?
Was ist ein Last Mile Expert?
Okay, IT-Systemadministrat.
Nein, sorry, nur IT-Administrator.
The Brain Factory.
Five Head, quasi.
Five Head by Design.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Administration und Implementierung
von interner IT-Infrastruktur.
Ja, das klingt passend.
Überwachung und Weiterentwicklung
bestehender Systeme zur Leistungssteigerung,
Risikomin- und Kostenreduktion.
Bisschen businessmäßig umschrieben,
aber passt halt auch dazu.
Ja, Lifecycle-Management
für Hard-on-Software.
Standardisierung und Automatisierung
von IT-Prozessen, Bereitstellung und Erweiterung,
Optimierung diverser
Policies, Exchange, Teams,
Exchange, Alter, geh mal weg.
Aber gut, sie brauchen es halt.
Das ist jetzt nicht negativ für den Laden.
Aber da hätte ich
ja keinen Bock drauf. Also alles, was
zu viel Microsoft-Kram beinhaltet,
ist für mich raus.
Ich suche eh nix.
Also hier, hallo, falls
mein Chef zuguckt.
Bereitstellung,
Konzeption, Implementierung und
Optimierung von Cloud- oder Hybridlösung,
Primär Microsoft 365
und Azure. Immerhin,
immerhin,
Microsoft 365
und nicht mehr wie die
Noobs Office 365.
Also was sie
schreiben.
Migration in die
Clouds sowie die Begleitung von spannenden
Projekten gehören zum Daily Business.
Verantwortung für das Client- und Benutzermanagement
AD, Azure-AD, Entra-ID.
Ja, das ist das gleiche.
Ich find's aber gut, dass sie
die Schnellanzeige up-to-date haben mit den
korrekten Namen.
Das macht auf mich immer einen guten Eindruck.
Auch wenn ich keinen Bock hätte
auf Microsoft.
Zusammenarbeit mit externen Dienstleistern
an Systemen und...
...
Dokumentation von
Oh ja, das machen alle besonders gerne.
Ich kenne...
Das liebt jeder Admin und
Entwickler und jeder mag das überhaupt.
Ich find das ganz geil. Das Ding ist halt,
die sind alle nicht
Wubbler Certified. Wenn die Wubbler Certified
wären, dann wüssten die, wenn man die
Sachen einfach fehlerfrei macht, dann braucht
man keine Dokumentation. Weil
sie funktionieren ja. Dokumentation
brauchst du ja nur, wenn das kaputt ist
und du willst nachgucken,
was denn da jetzt eigentlich passiert. Wenn es
einfach funktioniert, brauchst du keine Dokumentation.
Ganz einfach.
Easy.
Das zeichnet sie aus.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Beruf.
Übliche Sache. Mindestens 5 Jahre Praxiserfahrung.
5 Jahre Praxis?
Könnte man dem zumindest noch mal ein Senior dran
pappen und ein bisschen mehr Kohle bezahlen, oder?
Problemlösungskompetenz
mit der Fähigkeit Prioritäten zu setzen.
Okay, schnelle...
Sehr gute Kenntnisse im Umgang mit Windows
Active Directory, Azure Android, die...
Exchange, SharePoint sowie Windows
und Linux-Servern.
Das ist halt in Kombination immer
so ein Ding.
Also ich kenne Windows-Leute,
die jahrelang Windows gemacht haben und
jetzt bei Linux hängen geblieben sind und mit
Windows nichts mehr zu tun haben wollen.
Den umgedrehten Fall,
Linux-Leute, die auch ein bisschen Windows machen,
kenne ich nicht. Gibt es nicht.
Gefühlt. Gibt es einfach nicht.
Das liegt aber
auch daran, weil du siehst, wie angenehm
das sein kann und dann loggst du dich auf ein
Windows-System ein und musst kotzen.
Exzellente deutsche
Kenntnisse. Leute, nicht...
Exzellente brauchen die. Richtig.
Die sind so pfeifert, dass...
Exzellente. Wort und Schrift
C2
Also das ist noch nicht mal Muttersprachniveau,
das ist quasi noch besser, oder wie?
Moment.
C2, C1... Ich muss jetzt mal kurz
gucken.
Annähernd muttersprachliche Kenntnisse.
Ah ja.
Man soll halt
gut Deutsch können.
Sehr gut
Englisch kennen sollen. Mindestens B2.
Was ist B2?
Selbstständige Sprachverwendung. Okay, das kriege ich
gerade noch so hin.
We are all sitting in one boat.
Das bieten wir. Nutzen Sie die Chance.
Teil einer einzigen...
Das sind immer so Sprüche, Mann!
Juckt das irgendjemand, der sich
eine Bewerbung durchliest?
Hat das schon irgendjemand irgendwann mal
überzeugt, so was in der Bewerbung, Mann?
Spannende
internationale Projekte im hochmotivierten,
sehr kollegialen Team. Persönliche
Entwicklungs...
Leistungsorientierte Vergütung mit attraktivem
B...Buff?
Altersvorsorge?
Ihre Sprachkenntnisse fördern Sie mit...
Okay. Premium Bubble Account.
Viel Sp... Sag mal, hat Bubble
und Bubblefish was miteinander zu tun?
Das war früher so ein Desktop-Übersetzer.
Viel Spaß, Entfallungsmöglichkeiten
auf flache Echtigkeit, sofortiger Einstieg.
In Vollzeit über uns.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Die Stellanzeige ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ist jetzt aber auch nix,
was mich irgendwie so in Verzückung versetzt,
wo ich sage, oh ja, also, ich persönlich
eh nicht, weil viel zu viel Windows.
Die Stellanzeige
ist okay.
Nix, wo ich sagen würde, oh, Instant-Bewerbung ist
raus, aber die ist schon okay.
Also, sag mal, ich hab schon viel, viel, viel
schlechtere gesehen.
So, super, oh, ich muss da jetzt hin.
Ist es aber auch nicht.
Weiß ich, Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Ich finde, es ist so
semi-gut, okay.
Hat sich bemüht.
Solide, ja, genau,
das trifft's ganz okay.
Ja, das trifft's ganz gut, solide.
Solide, ganz okay, ja.
Genau, solide Stellanix-Weltbewegendes,
genau so seh ich das auch.
Also, wenn man da Bock drauf hat, Leute,
und ihr kommt aus der Nähe von Landshut,
die eine, die bei uns mal den Euro, die für uns,
für Deutschland mal den Eurovisions-
Contest gewonnen hat,
Lena irgendwas,
Landshut, ne, wie hieß,
wie hieß die?
Ach, Landruth, okay, ja,
passt, ähnlich, ähnlich.
Kann man machen.
So.
Ja, Emre, was war denn, was war denn
jetzt deine Stellanzeige? Dann machen wir die als nächstes.
Du wartest jetzt ja anscheinend schon eine Weile drauf.
Ich weiß nicht, welche,
welche das ist.
Oder hast du die letztes Mal gepostet?
Nicht heute.
Die Sachen vom letzten Mal haben wir alle durch.
Ja, Budget ist immer
interessant, ja, da drücken sie sich immer.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sich da so viele Läden
verdrücken. Auf der anderen Seite, ich hab euch
die Story ja schon erzählt, ne,
ein Kollege hat sich bei einem Laden beworben,
Budget 95 bis 105k,
Bewerbungs,
äh,
Orgie durchgemacht,
mit,
ähm,
Lern-Termin und dann online
nochmal irgendein Szenario durchgespielt und
immer hieß das so nach dem Motto, ja, passt alles gut,
äh, Seniorstelle, Budget
passt auch. Und am Ende, als
die fertig waren, wo es dann drum ging, den Vertrag
ihm zu schicken, haben die ihm gesagt,
oh, das Budget wurde doch
nicht genehmigt, es ist jetzt keine Seniorstelle mehr,
es gibt jetzt nur noch maximal 78k
oder sowas. Und dann hat er halt
gesagt, jep, dann halt nicht.
Ist halt für beide Seiten scheiße,
weil du hast dich lange dann
mit dem Laden beschäftigt, der Laden hat sich lange mit einem
potenziellen Kandidat beschäftigt, fragt
man sich halt auch, wenn es schon so losgeht,
will man dann da wirklich arbeiten?
Ja?
Und ich denk mir halt so, was denken die
sich denn? Denken die ernsthaft?
Oh, jetzt hat uns der Kandidat
kennengelernt, findet uns ganz toll,
wenn das erste, wenn das erste,
was er von uns hört ist, äh,
wir halten uns nicht an das, was vereinbart war,
dann wird er bestimmt sagen, oh ja, jetzt
komm ich um, jetzt komm ich sofort zu euch, oder wie?
Ja, also, da kann man,
also was ich sagen will ist, man kann selbst,
wenn da Budget steht, oder die
einen was sagen, auch nicht zwangsläufig
was drauf geben, aber ich fände es sinnvoll, wenn es
dabei steht.
Laokun?
Kun?
Weiß gar nicht, wie man die ausspricht.
Okay.
Hackerman! Jawoll, das gucken wir uns
gleich an.
Lamakun?
Lamajun?
Weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Das ist aber
so Pizza in der Richtung, so türkische,
ne, nicht wirklich Pizza,
das ist so ein,
ja so, so was in der Richtung,
ne, so ein, ja doch,
so was wie Pizza ist das, glaube ich.
Äh, ich muss ja sagen,
ich habe eine ganze Zeit lang,
äh,
äh, Pide, äh, Pide,
wie nennt sich das dann, dieses, dieses
Teig-Schiff da, Pide mit Sucuk,
fand ich eine ganze Zeit lang
viel, viel nicer als
klassische Salami-Pizza.
Mittlerweile habe ich wieder
ein bisschen mehr Richtung Italienisch
geschwenkt.
Das ist so eine Pizza, ist das?
Hier, guck, genau das.
So eine Art Pizza.
So, ähm,
also was haben die denn hier am Start,
zeigt mal her. Erstmal
eine Webseite,
die dir nicht die Augen rausbrennt.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Kennst du die nur gerollt?
Oh, wisst ihr, wo ich jetzt
richtig Bock drauf hätte,
wo wir gerade bei gerollt sind?
Auf Kalzone-Pizza hätte ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf.
Was ist da klassischerweise
immer drin? Salami, Schinken, Pilze?
So richtig knusprig
außen drum herum. So, so eine
Kalzone-Pizza, boah, da hätte ich richtig Bock
drauf jetzt.
Da würde ich, da würde ich jetzt, egal ob ich schon was
gefuttert habe oder nicht,
würde ich jetzt noch eine Runde
Pepo-Fett mir reinhauen.
Äh, jaja, ich habe schon was gegessen.
Tatsächlich was Gesundes.
So, so Müsli mit Obstschnipsel
drin. Aber Kalzone-Pizza,
hätte ich mega Bock drauf jetzt, ey.
Okay. Deine Karriere
bei Laocoon?
Ich bin immer noch über die Frage, wie man das ausspricht.
Security.
Hacke und wachse
gemeinsam mit uns
im Team. Auf geht's.
Endlich muss das
passende, die passende Stimmung für die
Stellenanzeige hier am Start haben.
Also.
Arbeitgeber, der sich nach dir richtet.
100% cooles Team.
20% Weiterbildungszeit.
100% Homeoffice. Das ist doch schon mal
eine Ansage, oder?
Wahrscheinlich ist das ein kleines
Startup, die gar kein Büro gemietet
haben. Deswegen 100% Homeoffice, aber
ey, soll mir recht sein.
Okay.
Offene Stellen.
Senior Penetration Tester.
Junior Penetration Tester.
Pentest Trainee.
Oh fuck, Telefonnummer liegt.
Guck mal, die machen auch
Kubernetes.
Kybernetz.
Wir sind ein Team von erfahrenen Hackern,
deren Arbeit es beginnt...
Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Metasploit kenn ich.
Die anderen zwei kenn ich
erst gar nicht.
Ach, soll ich euch mal was witziges von der Arbeit erzählen?
Ich hab letztens unsere Penetration Tester
gepenetration testet.
Es werden bei uns auf der Arbeit regelmäßig
Phishing-Mails verschickt von irgendwelchen
Penetration Testern,
die dann halt gucken, wie viele Leute klicken da drauf
und sonst was.
Und ich hab mal die URL mal rauskopiert,
die in dieser Phishing-Mail drinne
war, und mal
ausprobiert, was da
so läuft drauf.
Und sie hatten zumindest
einen offenen SSH-Port,
allerdings keine Passwort-Authentifizierung
an.
Aber
sie hatten SMTP offen.
Und ich hab den jetzt
eine E-Mail geschickt, per Telnet.
Per SMTP.
Mal gucken, ob die ankommt.
Und ich hab die Seite
ein paar Mal aufgerufen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob in der nächsten
Penetration-Auswertung
irgendwie drinne steht, der Link wurde
irgendwie 600 Mal aufgerufen.
Dann frag ich mich so, okay, haben die richtig
gefiltert? Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, SSH-Login... Aber das war
bei Hetzner gehostet.
Es war bei Hetzner gehostet.
Wenn man die jetzt hätte ärgern wollen,
hätte man die an Hetzner schicken können.
Hätte man die an Hetzner schicken können.
Ja, es war eine
URL mit einer ID pro
User hintendran.
Also im Endeffekt,
ich hab die mit
der ID Kekkel aufgerufen.
Die wird es ja nicht geben.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was da bei der Auswertung rauskommt.
Okay, offene Stellen.
Gut, macht jetzt keinen Sinn.
Ja, ohne ID
habe ich auch getestet.
Gab es eine ganz normale
HTTP
Response.
Hab da nur einen Curl drauf gemacht.
Gut, das muss ich mir jetzt nicht weiter angucken.
Das ist
nicht wirklich da, wo meine
Expertise jetzt sonderlich
groß ist, wo ich da viel dazu sagen könnte.
Aber
ich muss sagen, ich finde die Aufmachung der
Seite und wie sich das hier anhört
tatsächlich relativ
ansprechend.
Es ist so ein bisschen
knappmäßig hier auf jeden Fall alles, oder?
Ja.
Ich glaube,
wenn man auch sowas Bock hat
und die passenden Skills hat,
ist das bestimmt nice.
Guck mal, die schreiben sogar die
Kohle rein hier.
Als Senior Penetrator aus der Red Team kannst du bei uns inzwischen
fünfundse... Ja, gut.
Das ist halt eine super...
Das ist ja fast eine Spanne von
100 Prozent. Das ist das Doppelte.
Das ist das Doppelte.
Das ist halt schon...
Ja, okay.
Aber immerhin. Immerhin. Ich find's gut, wenn sowas
drinsteht. Ja.
Ja, wir geben zwischen wenig und viel Geld.
Aber ist okay. Find ich nicht
schlecht. Auch, dass sie direkt sagen,
Alter, Homeoffice. Wir haben gar kein
Büro in dem Sinn.
Ja. Nicht verkehrt.
In dem Bereich als
Senior Penetrator ist das auf jeden Fall nicht
die Welt.
Das hätt ich... Ey, das hätt ich mal ausprobiert.
Als ID irgendwie
Semikolon
Drop Table. Aber da war keine Datenbank
dahinter. Geh ich ganz stark
von aus. Das war einfach nur irgendein lackischer
Nginx.
Wo dann im Endeffekt in den Logs geguckt wird,
wer hat die Seite aufgerufen.
Ja, das ist nur ein bissl wenig. Da kommst du ja gar nicht
über die Runden. So.
Also weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier? Entwickle moderne Apps.
Also Chat, wenn ihr noch was habt, ne?
Wir haben Zeit. Nur her damit.
Und falls ich's nicht übersehe... Falls ich's übersehe,
muss ich nämlich nochmal
addwobblos dabei schreiben.
Wen haben wir denn hier als nächstes?
Entwickler für moderne Apps.
Menz?
Ja, Menz.
Heißt das.
Menz in München.
Vollzeit und Teilzeit.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Das wird schon in Datenbank geschrieben. Die durchsuchen nicht durch Logs.
Warum?
Ich würd das machen.
Du rechnest da im Endeffekt mit, keine Ahnung,
kann ich drei, vierhundert aufrufen bei sowas?
Klar, warum nicht?
Ich würd da keine Datenbank einschreiben.
Ich würd in die Logs die Aufrufe gucken.
Gutes.
TTT IT AG. Mit Sicherheit an ihrer Seite.
Okay.
Jetzt gucken wir uns aber erst mal Menz an.
Sie suchen einen Entwickler für moderne Apps.
Was moderne Apps sind,
ist natürlich jetzt
eine
große Bandbreite. Da stellen sich
sicherlich, wenn du fünf Leute fragst,
kriegst du fünf Antworten.
Aber die sind schon mal so modern,
dass die alle zusammen um den Macbook rumsitzen
und draufgucken und begeistert aussehen.
Wir wollen als Digita-
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was?
Oh, Buzzword Bingo geht los.
Wir wollen als Digital Pathfinders
Oh, Leute, jetzt.
Junior.
Ein Senior C-Sharp Softwareentwickler.
Interessant.
Borussia.de
Ob wir das alle schaffen? Kann schon sein.
Also,
als digitale Pathfinders
die Mobilität
von morgen mitgestalten und mit unseren
Produkten bei der Verkehrsunterschützung
um eine nachhaltigere Zukunft
ehrenwerte Ziele
Deswegen sehen die auch so.
Das geht natürlich nur auf dem Mac.
Das sollte ja allen klar sein.
Dazu haben wir ein...
Wir bieten Richtungsweise auf.
Planeroptimierung, Verkehrs...
Suchen wir dich
für die Entwicklung von modernen
Apps.
Wie sieht dein...
Wie sieht dein Alltag aus?
Du begeisterst dich für Mobilität
und daraus...
Du hast ein starkes Interesse daran
an nationalen
und internationalen Produkten zu arbeiten,
die die Mobilität von morgen
maßgeblich prägen.
Da wäre ich doch genau richtig so als alter Bahnflamer, oder?
Ich habe ein
großes Interesse an Mobilität.
Ja, fick die Bahn, Mann.
Ist doch schon...
Du hast ein starkes Interesse...
Du bist bereits Neues zu den
Neutechnologien und Produktfelder
oder individuelle Fähigkeiten.
Du bringst sehr gute Kenntnisse
in der Appentwicklung
in Android, IOS oder im Cross...
Plattform...
Achso, oder im Cross...
Das ist einfach nur...
Okay, das habe ich falsch gelesen,
aber das ist auch blöd geschrieben.
Oder im Cross-Plattform-Framework Flutter mit.
Flutter bin ich Experte.
Kann ich auch beweisen.
Kann ich beweisen.
Ich bin Flutter-Expert.
Ja.
Meine Flutter-App.
Viele Sachen starten.
Beste App überhaupt.
Es wird Zeit, Leute.
Ich würde sagen,
Zeit Start-Up zu gründen, oder?
Also, wenn das
jetzt mal nicht dafür reichen sollte,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also für die erste Flutter-App hier.
Beste App, oder?
Erste Flutter-App hier.
Ja, also ich glaube,
das geht als Bewerbung
direkt raus.
Du hast Kenntnisse
in aktuellen Mobile-Betriebssystemen,
Stores und Ökosystemen.
Du kennst dich in moderner Software-Entwicklung,
Software-Architektur und qualifizierst dich immer aus.
Du hast richtig Lust auf das Thema.
Du bist motiviert, neugierig auf neue IT-Systeme,
Technik in der IT-Welt. Du arbeitest selbstständig,
zuverlässig, exakt. Hast Freude an Sachen.
Mit anderen Menschen, okay.
Kein Bock an der Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Menschen.
Einfach Clip einchecken
und die lassen sich, genau,
mit dieser krassen Flutter-App,
da bewerben die sich bei mir.
Ja, wollte ich, aber das machen wir heute.
Du bringst Spaß und Bereitschaft mit
als Systemvergleicher.
Du hast eine Zertifizierung
zum AWS Practitioner,
oder ich sag absichtlich AWS,
weil ich AW,
weil W legit
die dümmste Aussprache eines Buchstabens
ever ist.
Du bist AWS Practitioner
oder vergleichbares Cloud-Wissen.
Weiterführen,
okay, blablabla.
Du hast Linux, Windows und seine Standard-Tools.
Flexible
Gleitzeiten, zentrale
Anbindungen, Bio-Kaffee aus
der regionalen Rösterei.
Der Obstkorb ist auch am Start.
Teamübergreifende Events
wie Wandern, Skifahren. Alter,
lasst mir in meiner Freizeit doch die Ruhe. Aber cool
für diejenigen, die da Bock drauf haben.
Okay Leute, ich sag euch mal ernst ehrlich, was ich davon halte.
Ich glaub, das ist
eine, ein cooler
Job für Leute,
die nicht so sind wie ich.
Das ist,
das klingt super Startup-mäßig
und
ja, man muss
sich sehr begeistern können
für dieses Themengebiet.
Man darf nicht die Erwartung
haben, viel Kohle zu verdienen,
ist mein Eindruck davon.
Zumindest nicht direkt.
Ja, und man muss halt auf
hippe, junge Leute
muss man mögen.
Ich glaube, wenn
einen das anspricht,
dann ist das echt nicht verkehrt.
Das macht kein, also ich glaube, die Stellenanzeige
ist insofern
gut, als dass sie
genau das transportiert, was sie
transportieren soll.
Ich glaube, ist nicht schlecht,
wenn man da Bock drauf hat.
Ich nicht.
Wenn das hier jemand anspricht,
ist das glaube ich nicht verkehrt.
So, next.
Ja, aber Startup
bekommst du immer wenig Kohle.
Es sei denn, du bekommst Anteile,
bleibst lange genug dabei
und der Kram wird dann irgendwann mal
super viel wert oder verkauft.
Gelder sehen stabil aus.
Da habe ich mich vielleicht geirrt,
aber so wirkt das.
Sie haben ja geschrieben, das ist irgendwie
so ein Fünf-Mann-Unternehmen aus ehemaligen
Studienkollegen.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es nicht schlecht,
aber halt überhaupt nichts für mich.
Plus Line-on.
Wie viele von diesen komischen Jobseiten
gibt es eigentlich?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Das ist jetzt schon irgendwie die achte Seite heute.
Früher hat man noch bei
Meine Stadt geguckt und sowas.
Ja, okay, ich gebe zu, das war
2005, 2004.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Meine Stadt?
Das sieht immer noch genauso hässlich aus,
wie damals.
Okay, also was haben wir denn hier?
Plus Line?
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Ja, genau!
Sie kommen aus Frankfurt.
Das kenne ich. Das sagt mir was.
Plus Line?
Kommt mir bekannt vor.
Okay, der Name kommt mir irgendwie
bekannt vor. Gut, ich meine Frankfurt
und Umgebung, so ein paar Sachen hast du halt einfach schon gehört.
Aha.
Die Boni für Recruiter, die sind ziemlich
nice.
Ich habe mal was irgendwo aufgeschnappt,
dass irgendeiner drei Monatsgehälter bekommt.
Wobei das sicherlich auch schon
outdated ist. Heute bist du...
Okay, wenn du komplett
vermittelst, also dass du quasi nicht
dem Typ nur den Job vermittelst,
sondern die Leute vermittelst, dann
kriegst du ja monatlich dafür was.
Okay, also
sucht ab sofort in Frankfurt
Hybrid oder Remote?
Okay.
Sie suchen einen Junior System Engineer
Linux, also quasi
mich in jung.
Also ich würde das machen,
wenn ich dann auch wieder im richtigen Alter wäre.
Also wenn die mich jetzt resetten können
auf sagen wir mal so 25,
dann würde ich das machen.
Es gibt doch Seniorstellen auch, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur das, was der Chat mir
gepostet hat. Ja, das ist
exakt meine
Jobbezeichnung.
Also ich würde den Job machen, wenn die mich resetten
können auf 25.
Ich will nicht das Jahr resetten.
Ich will nicht, dass es wieder irgendwie
oder so ist, ja.
Ich will 2024 haben
und 25 wieder sein. Das ist okay.
Dann würde ich den Job machen.
Egal was die mir bezahlen. 15,
also quasi 15 Jahre resetten
können die mir dann, müssen die mir gar nichts.
Das mache ich umsonst. Okay, also
gesucht ab sofort in Frankfurt
Hybrid und Remote. Wir bieten
...
Kopf und du weißt überhaupt nicht, was die von dir wollen.
Wie kommst
du zu dieser Einstellung? Zu welcher?
Du meinst, dass ich
in 2024 wieder 25
sein will?
Ja, weil 25 sein nicer ist, als fast
40 sein.
Ganz einfach.
Was ich nicht will, ist, dass wieder 2010 ist.
Ich habe ja keinen Bock, noch mal
die gleichen 15 Jahre zu erleben.
Ich hätte gerne einfach jetzt
jetzt plus, also quasi
minus 15 Jahre vom Alter her.
Das ist doch nice.
Mit 25 bist du dann auch einfach viel
weiß ich
viel, viel jünger
und funzt alles noch besser
als mit fast 40.
Das ist jetzt nicht so als
viel agiler. Da kannst du diagonal
skalieren mit 25, wenn du das
richtige Grindset-Mindset hast.
Du musst das richtige Business machen.
Ich hätte echt kein Problem
damit, wenn ich 15 Jahre jünger wäre wieder.
Wir bieten dir einen attraktiven Eindruck.
Okay, sagen wir schon.
Okay, wenn du Begeisterung
für Linux und Open Source mitbringst,
durch komplexe Hosting-Plattformen,
professionelle Virtualisierungstechniken
und aktuellste Automatisierungssysteme
wie zum Beispiel Ansible und Puppet.
Okay, Puppet ist nicht
aktuellste Automatisierungssysteme.
Puppet ist so Legacy-Kram,
den eigentlich alle gerade loswerden wollen.
Also nicht wirklich Legacy in Form von
nicht mehr supported, aber du findest so gut wie keine
Leute mehr dafür. Du aber auch
Projekte im Bereich Kubernetes,
IT-Secure-Management,
Cloud-Spannung findest, bist du...
Klingt gut?
Finde ich tatsächlich
eine gelungene,
bis auf die steile Lernkurve, finde ich eine
gute Introduction.
Es ist
nicht Selbstbeweihräucherung
von so einem halben Roman,
Selbstbeweihräucherung. Es ist kurz und knackig und
die passenden Buzzwords drinnen,
außer Puppet vielleicht jetzt, was die
Leute, die sowas mögen,
anspricht.
Das Intro finde ich schon mal nicht schlecht.
Ach ja, derjenige, der das gepostet hat,
arbeitest du da oder willst du dich da bewerben?
Also, äh,
BashDruid.
Der Name passt schon mal.
Also, wenn es um Linux-Shells und so geht.
Was ersetzt Puppet?
Dachte, es wird noch für Windows-Provisioning.
Also, als ich Puppet und Windows-Provisioning
in Kombination gesehen habe,
war das grausam schlecht.
Ganz einfach, Windows professionierst du nicht,
du verwendest einfach kein Windows.
Was wir dir zutrauen, ist, dass du nicht nur Windows-Provisionierst, sondern auch Windows-Provisionierst.
komplexe Cloud-Lösungen auf
und packe weiter Virtualisierung mit an.
Entwicke Lösungen für Probleme noch, bevor diese entstehen.
Proaktiv sozusagen.
AI-based Troubleshooting.
Dokumentiere dein...
Die sind auch nicht Wubbler-certified.
Die ganzen Kack-Noobs, Alter.
Dokumentation, Mensch.
Der Kram muss einfach funktionieren.
Toll, wenn du das hier mitbringst.
Abgeschlossenes IT-Ausbildung.
Spaß an euren Herausforderungen.
Echtes Interesse an Linux und Open Source.
Sicherer Umgang mit der Kommandozeile und dem Editor.
Ja, gut, dass das drin steht.
Interesse an zusätzliche Verdienstmöglichkeiten
im Rahmen einer Rufbereitung.
Okay, why not?
Wichtig sind sehr gute Deutschkenntnisse,
Wort und Schrift.
Führerschein der Klasse B.
Aber wichtiger als erlernte Skills
sind uns dein Mindset.
Die High-Performer sind am Start.
Dein Mindset und der Wille etwas Neues.
Das finde ich aber gut, dass das da steht.
Das finde ich auch oftmals wichtiger,
als das, dass du eine Sache gut kannst.
Viel wichtiger ist, dass die Leute gut passen
zu dem jeweiligen Unternehmen,
vor allem zu dem jeweiligen Team.
Und dass es Leute sind, die sich halt einarbeiten
und sich das angucken.
Das dauert ein bisschen,
aber dann hast du wenigstens jemand,
der Ahnung hat,
von dem, wie es das Unternehmen braucht.
Weil ganz im Ernst,
nur weil du Ansible kannst,
weil du Terraform kannst,
weil du mit irgendwelchen Cloud-Sachen
und Kubernetes schon mal was gemacht hast,
heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass du weißt,
wie das jeweilige Unternehmen das genau benutzt
und was sie damit machen.
Das ist immer nur die halbe Miete,
die Tools zu kennen.
Die zweite Hälfte ist,
okay, was machen die damit?
Deswegen finde ich es tatsächlich ganz gut,
dass sie das geschrieben haben.
Nicht ganz, was eine Karriere,
das seid, okay.
Also ehrlich, ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Verantwortung, Freiraum von Anfang an,
steile Lernkurve durch Komplexe.
Naja, das ist eher so.
80% ITler, die gerne ihr Wissen teilen.
Was ist denn ein 80% ITler?
Teilzeit?
Nee.
Was ist ein 80% ITler?
Wollen die nicht einen 100% ITler?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Okay, den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Chef hat ebenfalls einen technischen Background.
Das finde ich nice, dass das da steht.
Die wissen schon mal, was oftmals problematisch ist.
20% Random Shit.
Leistungsgerechtes Gehalt, Urlaubs- und Weihnachtsgeld.
Sagen sie alle.
Flexible Arbeitszeit, Arbeitsmodelle.
Gut, dass Homeoffice drin steht.
Top Ausstand im Laptop und Diensthandy.
Ja gut, Diensthandy muss, wenn ihr wollt,
dass man Berufsbereitschaft macht.
Muss das sein.
30% kostenfreies Jobticket, zentrales Office nahe Hauptbahnhof.
Vielleicht habe ich die da schon mal gesehen.
Mir kommt der Name übelst bekannt vor.
Jobrat, Freizeit, Fitnessstudio, Snacks, Getränke und Kaffeebar.
Timi, geh mal fort.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist die Stellenanzeige.
Ich sage absichtlich nicht, dass es die beste Stellenanzeige ist heute.
Aber das ist die Stellenanzeige, die mich persönlich von dem, was mich interessiert,
bisher am meisten anspricht.
Das andere waren halt einfach auch Sachen dabei,
die überhaupt nicht so mein Themengebiet sind.
Mit Windows oder Verkehrskram in Berlin und sowas.
Aber das ist die Stellenanzeige, die mich noch am ehesten anspricht heute.
Leider vermute ich mal, bezahlen sie nicht so viel.
Weil sie schreiben nicht umsonst Junior davor.
Haben die auch, okay, dein Job.
Okay, es gibt auch noch einen normalen.
System-Engineer Linux.
Windows, MonkaS, Alter.
Wollen die da was anderes?
Okay, da wollen sie tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr haben.
Da steht auch, das finde ich cool, da steht da tatsächlich auch ein bisschen mehr.
Linuxbasierte Serverlandschaft, Hosting, ich spreche die Sprache der Kunden.
Auch wenn ich mit Kunden nicht allzu viel zu tun habe.
Qualität und Verlöse, Problemverteiler der Investoren.
Drei Jahre Erfahrung, sichere Umgang mit Kommandozeile, Betriebssystem, CentOS, Red Hat.
Debian, sehr gute, bei SQL, MonkaS, ja gut, warum nicht.
Gängiger Open Source Software, Apache, Nginx, Vanish.
Okay, ich bin ein Noob, ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Gehört, habe ich es schon mal, aber ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, was es ist.
Äh, what?
Reverse Caching Proxy.
Aha, okay.
Äh, Tomcat, Wildfly, Postfix, Dove.
Ah, die machen auch E-Mails selbst.
Das ist auch mal was.
Erfahrung, Ansible, Puppet, KVM, Red Hat, ich hoffe nicht.
Grundlegendes Verständnis von Programmiersprachen, PHP, Python, Java, Java, Shell Scripting, gutes Englisch.
Also vom Skillset her würde ich sagen, passt das heute von den ganzen Stellenanzeigen noch am besten.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil die Stellenanzeige ist auch gut und ansprechend,
dass der Chef wirklich Ahnung von...
...Technik hat und es nicht nur dasteht, weil irgendjemand ist verantwortlich für die Stellenanzeige.
Äh, oh, was hast du geschrieben? Habe ich nicht gesehen.
Äh, ups.
Alter, äh, Quitsch.
Nee, war aber nicht.
Was ist denn?
Da.
Frage, bisschen out of Context.
Wie angemessen findest du 75k pro Jahr für 4 Jahre Erfahrung plus 2 Jahre Ausbildung?
Habe ein Bachelor und der Titel ist Plattform-Ingenieur.
Also, das kann man.
Äh, klingt erstmal pauschal.
Nicht so übel.
Man kann das jetzt allerdings nicht so global sagen, weil das hängt immer sehr von Region und Branche ab.
Ja, Frankfurt Finanzbranche geht durchaus mehr.
Aber insgesamt klingt das erstmal gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Es kommt halt wie gesagt auf Branche und Region an, aber insgesamt würde ich sagen, ja.
Ja.
Nicht verkehrt.
Hast du eine Meinung zu Management-IT-Jobs, sowas wie Business-Analyse, Require...
Ja, lass, da habe ich eine Meinung dazu, lass mich in Ruhe damit.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass es Leute gibt, die das freiwillig machen.
Dann muss ich es nicht machen.
Ich könnte das auch gar nicht.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Die hatten wir gerade schon.
Jetzt haben wir TTT-IT.
Die Leute erzählen viel Mist, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wenn du irgendjemand hast, der da schon länger dabei ist, je nachdem, kann das durchaus sein.
Aber wichtig ist, dass du damit zufrieden bist.
Selbe Position.
Ja, ähnliche Firma als heute.
Also, wichtig ist, dass du damit zufrieden bist.
Ich finde, also wie gesagt, man kann es natürlich klopfen.
Ich kann es auch normal nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Region, welche Branche und sonst was.
Aber ich finde 75k nach vier Jahren echt in Ordnung.
Damit verdienst du, glaube ich, eine ganze Ecke mehr als der Durchschnitt.
Ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich schon eher so Top 20, 25 Prozent oder so.
Hätte ich jetzt bauchgefühlmäßig gesagt.
Weil das Durchschnittsgeil ist echt nicht so hoch.
Äh, ganz so viel ist 75k auch wieder nicht.
Ich habe doch beim Spiegel letztens so eine Übersicht.
So, also was haben wir jetzt?
TTT IT AG.
Mit Sicherheit an ihrer Seite.
Mit Sicherheit auf ihrer Seite wäre mir eigentlich lieber.
Da weiß ich, dass ich nicht gebetet werde.
Arbeitszeit ist Lebenszeit.
Ja, da ist was dran.
Freude und Spaß bei der Arbeit ist die Basis.
Für Erfolg im Job.
Ja, okay.
Neben den individuellen Stärken unserer Mitarbeiter ist das Team...
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Auf höchstem Niveau dabei...
Okay.
Besuchen Sie uns auch auf einem YouTube.
Oh, gucke mal hier.
Jetzt wird es aber professional.
Wie, das war's?
Hält sich jetzt sehr in Grenzen.
Hey, warte mal.
Okay, also.
Das wird bestimmt wieder cringe Selbstpromotion-Video.
Selbstpromotion-Video.
Ähm.
Die suchen überhaupt nix.
Die suchen nur Azubis.
Wer hat denn das gepostet?
Willst du dich da bewerben als Azubi oder wie?
Bill in time?
Die suchen ernsthaft?
Okay, das ist selten.
Das habe ich ja glaube ich noch nie gesehen.
Dass jemand explizit nach der Ausbildung nach einem Fachinformatiker Systemintegration sucht.
Die suchen nach allem möglichen, aber nicht nach einem Fisi.
Okay.
Wir gehen ja direkt ins PDF.
Nice.
Okay.
Wir suchen ab sofort in Vollzeit Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Wir sind ein Erfolg.
Okay.
Deine Aufgaben, Konzeption und Office.
Warum alles so viel Microsoft Shit immer, Mensch?
Es gibt so viele nice Sachen.
Aber alle wollen sie in den Microsoft Shit machen.
Konfiguration und Administration von Windows Server wird ja immer schlimmer.
Also für mich persönlich, wenn ihr das mögt, kann das toll sein, ne?
Also insofern, aber für mich, ich würde da Anfälle bekommen, wenn, weil,
weil Windows und ich zusammen, das wird nix.
Okay.
Konzeption, Umsetzung, Betreuung von Virtual Hyper-V, vor allem, okay, das geht ja noch.
Aufbau und Betreuung von Kundennetzen, Eigenverantwortung.
Ja, Kunden.
Support, Kundenbetreuung, Softwareinstallation.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse in der Administration von Windows Servern.
Gute Kenntnisse im Bereich Netzwerktechnik, Firewalls, Routing, VPN und WLAN.
Sehr gute Hardwarekenntnisse, fundierte Kenntnisse im Bereich Virtualisierung,
Kenntnisse im, ist das Telefonanlagen oder sowas?
Berufsverfahren, okay.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen so sehr allgemein, aber.
Okay, ich lese daraus raus, sie suchen jemanden, der sich mit Windows auskennt und ein bisschen Netzwerk-Gramm machen kann noch.
Ja, für mich ist es nix.
Immerhin, und das muss man ihnen zugutehalten, schön kurz und knackig.
Weiß man Bescheid, bisschen mehr Details, was denn genau, wie, wo eingesetzt wird, vielleicht nicht verkehrt, aber geht, klar, ist nur noch 15 Stellen Anzeige.
Aber vielleicht wird es ja besser, wenn wir uns das Video dazu angucken.
Warte mal kurz, du bist auch ITler und wartest ständig auf Updates?
Dann mach doch einen Ar...
Hey, warte mal kurz.
Hey, im Headshot, der braucht den Fanatic Headshot Controller.
Du bist auch ITler und wartest ständig auf Updates?
Dann mach doch einen Arbeitgeber-Update und komm zu uns ins Team.
...Eine Herausforderung in deinem Leben haben...
Alter, was macht der mit seinen Fingern? Guckt euch das mal an.
Wenn du eine neue Herausforderung in deinem Leben haben willst, dann bist du bei uns genau richtig, weil bei uns ist jeden Tag eine neue Herausforderung, eine neue technische Innovation zu erleiden.
Jeden Tag eine neue technische Innovation, Alter, die haben aber mal einen ziemlich äußerst agil, diagonal skalierenden Workflow.
Mein Name ist Erik, arbeite bei der TGT IT AG.
Hier bin ich Senior Systems Engineer.
Meine Schwerpunkte sind neben der Windows-Welt Exchange und Citrix.
Also die bestehenden...
Exchange und Citrix, es wird ja immer schlimmer.
...Umgebungen auf neueren Stand zu migrieren.
Wenn du bei uns anfangen willst, wir freuen uns auf dich.
Hier erwarten dich auf jeden Fall spannende Herausforderungen und ein super, super Arbeitsklima.
Der Haupt-Benefit...
Wisst ihr, was die beste Antwort ist, die ihr geben könnt auf die Frage, warum wollen sie denn ausgerechnet bei uns arbeiten?
Musst du sagen, weil ich nicht unter der Brücke schlafen will, ich brauche Geld.
Finde ich neben der Stimmung diese Veranstaltung, die wir machen, dass die Leute Lust darauf haben, das sind mehrfach im Jahr.
Also auch viel neben dem normalen Arbeiten versuchen wir auch miteinander klarzukommen, was letztendlich natürlich auch...
Team-Events, jawohl!
...das Funktionieren, die Schnittstellen deutlich verbessern.
Ich bin Timo.
Nein, das sollt ihr natürlich nicht wirklich sagen.
TGT IT AG als...
Junior System Engineer im Bereich Infrastruktur.
Das wäre aber ehrlich.
Ich bin Marie Brenk, arbeite bei der TGT IT AG als Systems Engineer.
Ich kümmere mich eher um die...
Diese hippe Musik im Hintergrund.
...täglichen Support-Aufgaben.
Ansonsten benutze ich auch mal einen Schraubenzieher, wenn wir die Serverschränke lassen.
Da hätte ich auch mal wieder Bock drauf, Leute.
Ich sage es euch ehrlich.
Ich hätte echt wieder Bock, mal ins Rechenzentrum zu gehen und da ein bisschen Zeug einzubauen.
Ich habe das früher täglich gemacht.
Und jetzt jahrelang gar nicht mehr.
Ich würde das gerne mal wieder machen.
Jetzt nicht hauptberuflich oder so, aber ich würde gerne mal wieder zusammenbauen.
Eine neue Mitarbeiterin sollte Spaß an der Arbeit haben, Spaß am Umgang mit Menschen
und natürlich über gute Fachkenntnisse im IT-Bereich.
Also ganz ehrlich, die wenigsten ITler haben Bock und Spaß am Umgang mit Menschen.
Deswegen machen wir das ja auch.
Wir kennen uns alle inzwischen.
Weil wir zum größten Teil sonnenscheue Kellerkinder sind, die keinen Bock auf andere Leute haben.
Sehr gut.
Auch neue werden gut eingearbeitet.
Wir unterstützen uns.
Es gibt nichts zu glauben.
Hey, wenn du das, was du bisher gesehen hast, wenn dir das gefällt, wenn du in einer coolen Firma arbeiten willst,
mit tollen Leuten, mit einem tollen Team.
Also, zwei Sachen.
Es hat mich jetzt nicht irgendwie super überzeugt, dass ich da hin will.
Aber ich habe schon deutlich schlimmere Self-Promotion-Videos.
Gesehen als das.
Also, geht schon in Ordnung.
Ja, das Video könnte echt schlimmer sein.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Geht schon, geht schon.
Aber zu viel Windows.
Aber wenn ihr da Bock habt drauf, Leute, TTT-IT in...
Wo sind die überhaupt?
Ähm, Trio.
Okay.
Next.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
Ja, Leute, die hatten wir ja schon.
Okay, die mag ich schon mal.
Die haben eine Webseite.
Die nicht Flashbangt.
Selbst ohne Dark Reader.
Wo ist Murnau?
Am Staffelsee.
Okay.
Wo ist der Staffelsee?
Neben dem Riegsee.
Ja.
Wo ist das?
Das blaue Land.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Bayern, bestimmt, ne?
Warten, Kirchen.
Okay, da kommen wir schon eher.
Okay, Bayern.
Ganz im Süden.
Was würdest du statt Microsoft 365 eigentlich machen?
Ich habe keine großen Firma-Einsätze, nix, Microsoft 365.
Aber ich will mich nicht drum kümmern müssen.
Das Gute an Office ist nach wie vor, dass die Leute den Kram halt seit 20 Jahren kennen.
Ich persönlich mache, soweit es geht, einen großen Bogen um alles, was ich in Office machen muss.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist Office wahrscheinlich immer noch das Beste, was du verwenden kannst.
Irgendwer muss sich drum kümmern.
Ja, solange das du nicht ich bin, ist das okay.
Ach so, ASCII-Docs?
Nee.
Ich war meistens...
Wenn ich Sachen für mich mache, reines TXT, was man im Zweifelsfall als Markdown formatiert, irgendwie auch ein bisschen schöner rendern kann.
Und ansonsten, Presentation-Stells mache ich mittlerweile tatsächlich auch in PowerPoint.
Ich habe es lange Zeit auch in Markdown gemacht, dann als PDF exportiert.
Aber gucken wir mal, was Code-Werk haben möchte.
Oh, gucke mal.
Ein Senior C-Latten-Software-Entwickler.
Code-Werk steht für Technikbegeisterung, Innovation und Zuverlässigkeit mit flachen Hierarchien frei...
Okay.
Chat-GPT, generiere mir eine Einleitung für meine Stellenanzeige.
Ob in Zügen und Industrieanlagen, also dann für Windows 3.11 sozusagen.
Wir bringen die Systeme von morgen dazu, miteinander zu reden.
Dabei brauchen wir deine Hilfe.
Wir suchen clevere Köpfe für die Entwicklung von industriellen Software-Systemen für morgen.
Okay.
Deine Aufgaben.
Du bringst dein Wissen in unsere...
Okay, das ist bla bla.
Du verantwortest, gestaltest den gesamten Entwicklungsprozess, angefangen von den ersten Klärungen,
der Anfang über Konzeption, Design, Implementierung bis zur Übergabe an den Kunden.
Ja gut, das ist...
Sagen wir mal so, du bist nicht einfach nur Entwickler, du bist Senior-Entwickler.
Bei manch anderen wärst du vielleicht auch Architekt, wenn man sowas hier dann liest.
Aber, ja.
Du entwickelst und programmierst .NET C-Sharp.
Anwendungen, einschließlich GUI und Schnittstellen zu Fremdsystemen.
Ob die noch .NET Framework unter Windows-Only verwenden?
Es liest sich ein bisschen so.
Weil, ansonsten...
Ja gut, ich mein, du kannst auch .NET Core mit WPF und Windows Forms machen, das geht genauso, ja.
Aber die haben bestimmt noch jede Menge Legacy-Anwendungen.
.NET Framework 481.
Windows Forms.
Alles WPF-Zeug.
Ich mein, alle mal immer noch angenehmer als...
MAUI.
MAUI ist auch so ein richtig krasser Rohrkrepierer.
Ich warte jeden Tag auf den Blogpost, dass Microsoft sagt, MAUI wird...
Ähm...
MAUI wird eingestellt.
Wenn's .NET GUI sein soll, dann AVALONIA.
Also, vielleicht doch besser gar kein GUI in .NET.
Datenmodellierung, Entwicklung von Datenbanken und NoSQL-Systemen.
Du integrierst Anwendungen in Frameworks im Umfeld von Industrie 4.0 IoT.
Moment.
IoT ist jetzt neuerdings Industrie 4.0?
Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Geeignete Methoden, zum Beispiel aus der agilen Softwareentwicklung, nutzt du bei deiner täglichen Arbeit.
Ja, Moment, das ist vollkommen egal, ob ich Methoden aus der agilen Softwareentwicklung nutze.
Wenn nur ich das mache, hat das keinen Sinn.
Entweder macht es mein Team oder das Projekt.
Ja, oder es macht keinen Sinn.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ich arbeite agil alleine.
Und der Rest ist...
...der Leute, die an der Anwendung arbeiten, nicht.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ah, lass kurz Daily machen.
Ah, okay.
Ich bin...
Ich hab nix für heute.
Fertig.
Bin ja nur allein.
Also, macht irgendwie keinen Sinn.
Ich weiß, was sie meinen.
Ja, dass du sowas vielleicht schon mal gemacht hast.
Zu meinen Projekten war es so.
Irgendjemand hat halt agile Softwareentwicklung jetzt zum Mainstream-Standard erklärt, dass jeder agil Software entwickeln muss.
Und alle...
...denken halt, es ist cool, wenn man aus...
...wenn man agiles Softwareentwicklung einschreibt.
Die wenigsten Projekte sind wirklich agil.
Die schreiben, dass sie agil sind, weil es sich auf Manager-Ebene cool anhört und sich nice buzzword-bingo-mäßig verkaufen lässt.
Aber machen dann äußerst unagile Dinger.
Wie zum Beispiel, dass der Projektleiter auch das Scrum Master sein soll und sowas.
Das ergibt einfach gar keinen Sinn.
In deinen Projekten prüfst du die Anwendbarkeit neuer Technologien und Innovationsmöglichkeiten.
Das ergibt einfach keinen Sinn.
Okay?
Ja.
Macht Sinn.
Also, man muss prinzipiell immer die neuesten Frameworks und Technologien einsetzen und in keinem Projekt zweimal das gleiche.
Nee, aber das passt schon.
Also, man könnte den Satz ja auch so interpretieren.
Man sollte sich ein bisschen für neue Entwicklungen und Technik interessieren.
Und das ist Grundvoraussetzung dafür.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Wir bauen auf deinem Wissen und Know-How.
Diese Basis bringst du auf jeden Fall mit.
Okay.
Du hast einen abgeschlossenen Studium in Informatik, Media und vergleichbare Ausbildung.
Du bringst mehrjährige Erfahrungen in der Softwareentwicklung mit.
UML!
No!
God, please, no!
Macht das wirklich irgendjemand?
Die einzigen UML-Diagramme, die ich je gesehen habe, sag mal, im Business Enterprise Umfeld,
waren irgendwelche von, ja wahrscheinlich damals noch Eclipse automatisch generierten Dinger.
Ja, ansonsten habe ich das nie wirklich großartig in Verwendung gesehen.
Vielleicht liege ich da falsch.
Ich meine, das ist bekannt, ja, und das wird nicht umsonst sogar in der Ausbildung teilweise gemacht.
Aber ich habe es in freier Wildbahn, ich persönlich jetzt, noch nie im großen Stil gesehen.
Ihr macht auch viel?
Ja, das ist mal so unterschiedlich kann das sein.
.NET und Datenbanken kennst du nicht aus.
Dein Vorteil sind Erfahrungen in der GUI-Entwicklung.
Du verfügst über sehr gute Deutsch-Englisch-Kenntnisse, dich zeichnet analytisches und unternehmerisches Denken fällt dir leicht.
Warte...
Okay, du schaust über den Tellerrand hinaus, finde ich gut und am wichtigsten ist, du arbeitest gern mit anderen zusammen,
bist zufällig offen gegenüber neuen Themen.
Anspruchsvolle Abwechslungsreihe, Aufgabenzus internshipieren ...
Aha.
Geht klar, die Stellenanzeige.
Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so die in voller Vollendung, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, nice, sofort Bewerbung, raus für alle die da Bock drauf haben.
Ist okay, ja.
Was haben wir hier, Pearl-Jobs.
Alter!
viel von diesen komischen jobseiten gibt es denn moment die haben auch den fanatic headshot
controller systemadministrator und microsoft systemadministrator microsoft und infrastructure
jetzt jetzt habe ich liegt der vokal administration unserer hybriden microsoft umgebung office jetzt
fange ja auch schon an mit office markus auf 365 windows server active directory und der
zentral das ist so viel windows kram in tune es wird ja immer schlimmer man also für mich ich
sage nicht dass die stellanzeige schlecht ist nur für mich ich habe ich stehe halt komplett
auf kriegsfuß mit dem ganzen microsoft und dem betriebssystem und den betrieb das system
und vmware okay sie stellen den it betrieb unsere infos und das monitoring patch schwachstellen
life cycle management er auch gehabt aber einfach alles reingeschrieben so wie
kontinuierliche optimierung sicher außerdem unterstützen sie unsere mitarbeiter und
direkten kollegin wichtig dass das alles mwd ist nicht dass man irgendwie auf eine andere
idee kommen könne im servicemanagement bei ihnen tippe ihren täglichen herausforderungen second
and third level support warum nicht die besteuerung betreuen kollegen dienstleistern die verfügung
abgeschlossene ausbildung zudem sind sehr gut vertraut mit aktueller microsoft technologie
da sind sie bei mir genau richtig
die webseite sie auch wie von 2006 aus ja vor allem die
okay kollegiales und 30 tage urlaub kostenzuschuss was die kinder betreut das natürlich nicht schlecht
möglichkeit zum jobrad wer es braucht ich habe mir das neue fahrrad einfach so gekauft kein
bock auf jobrad erhalten von mitarbeitervergünstigung auf pearl produkt ob es noch den headshot controller gibt
Möglichkeit zur Teilnahme an
Fitnessprogrammen, naja, also
also, ähm
ich muss sagen,
wer hat das gepostet?
Kodiak Husky
liest sich sehr 0815.
Kann man machen, wenn man da Bock
drauf hat, denke ich.
Also, springt einem jetzt nichts
entgegen, wo man sagen würde, Alter,
bloß nicht, wenn man in der
Microsoft-Welt unterwegs ist und da Bock
drauf hat, liest sich halt
sehr
ja
sehr uninspiriert
0815-Stellenanzeige.
Es steht zumindest immerhin
drinne, was du machst, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Nicht so wie die einen vorhin, so nach dem Motto
wir suchen einen Entwickler, für was, wissen wir
selber nicht, aber wir suchen einen Entwickler.
Achso, nee, die Frage war ja,
ob 2,5k
brutto okay sind.
2,5k brutto
klingt enorm wenig.
Ich mein, das sind
30.000 im Jahr
oder sowas. Das ist ja nix.
Nee.
Ja, wenn man es jetzt mal richtig macht.
Ich kann auch nicht richtig rechnen, man.
Das ist
definitiv zu wenig.
Ich bekomme in Teilzeit auch mehr.
Und selbst das sollte man nicht
unbedingt als Maßstab dann nehmen. Also, das ist
auf jeden Fall zu wenig.
Was passiert hier gerade im Chat?
Schickt ihr euch gerade Bewerbungen
gegenseitig zu oder was
treibt ihr hier?
Ja.
Möchtest du lieber ein Struktogramm?
Nee, nee, okay.
Wenn ich die Auswahl hätte und eins
davon verwenden muss, UML oder
Struktogramm. Wobei das Ding ist halt
UML und Struktogramme machen
unterschiedliche Sachen.
UML ist eher Klassenhierarchie.
Und was die, was die unterschiedlichen
Objekte an Methoden anbieten und
Struktogramm ist Anwendungslogik.
Beides für'n Arsch.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
wenig hier, Kodiakaski.
Also da würde ich sagen.
Also.
Da muss schon noch ein
bisschen mehr gehen.
So, guck mal, wie war man da?
Netzwerkadministrator.
Boah, das, das, das Flash bangt
ja eins schon wieder so richtig
krass hier.
Ach so.
Okay, Netzwerkadministrator für
Administration, Wartung, Überwachung
der LAN und WLAN Netzwerkinfrastruktur.
Ja, Firewall, Konzeption, Betrieb
und Segmentierung.
Konzeption in betriebnahen
Dokumentation.
Schon wieder.
Was haben die alle nur mit ihrer
Dokumentation heute?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Alle wollen sie, dass dokumentiert wird.
Es muss funktionieren.
Es muss nicht dokumentiert werden.
Der ständige Wachstum verfügbaren
Systeme, Troubleshooting, Analyse von
technischen Problemen.
Das liest sich auch sehr 0815.
Du hast ja abgeschlossen.
Okay, Standardsatz.
Du hast bereits Berufserfahrung in der
Administration.
Ja, du kennst dich aus mit Cisco und
D-Link.
Und optimalerweise mit Zertifizierung.
Ja gut, im Cisco Umfeld mögen die
Zertifizierungen unglaublich.
Und die Cisco Zertifizierungen sind
tatsächlich nicht so easy, wie man
denkt.
Also meine höchste Cisco Zertifizierung
ist die kleinste, die es gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Gibt es CCNA noch?
Ich habe einen CCNA, aber der ist so
alt, der ist schon längst abgelaufen.
Außerdem halte ich von Zertifizierungen
nix.
Er sagt doch, der ist abgelaufen.
Gut.
Das ist gut.
Gutes System dokumentiert sich
selbst.
Richtig, Niklas.
Und noch besser, ein gutes System
funktioniert.
Und wenn es funktioniert, muss es
nicht dokumentiert sein.
Ist doch logisch.
Du arbeitest zielstrebig, strukturiert,
ergebnisorientiert.
Weil du weißt, worauf es in deinem
Beruf ankommt.
Du bist, bist du qualitäts- und
verantwortungsbewusst.
Als Mitarbeiter im IT-Service bist du
ausgesprochen dienstleistungsorientiert.
Weiß ich mal nicht, was die mir damit
sagen wollen.
Solche Sätze gibt es da öfters.
Ich glaube, die wollen dir damit
Schlüssel sagen. Du darfst nicht so
schnell abgefuckt sein von Anfragen von
dummen Usern. Du hast das Ziel
immer im Blick und stehst gerne in Kontakt mit
anderen. Dein verbind... Was?
Moment. Dein verbindliches
Auftreten und... Was ist denn ein
verbindliches Auftreten? Wie darf man sich das
denn vorstellen?
Chat, tretet mal verbindlich
auf, dass ich weiß, was damit gemeint ist.
Nicht zu spät kommen,
nicht rumdrucksen. Also
wenn ich sage, da arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck
dran, dann ist das gut, ja?
Da sind wir eh schon dran,
gerade bei all den Problemen.
Da sind wir dran. Und wenn wir da nicht dran sind,
nehm ich's mit.
Und deine Kommunikation ist das i-Tüpfelchen, das dich zum
perfekten Kandidaten für den Sofa... Wir bieten dir
einen Arbeitsplatz.
Nice! Das ist aber nett von euch, dass ihr mir
einen Arbeitsplatz bietet.
Ein hochwertiges, funktionales Arbeitsumfeld,
bei dem es dir an nichts fehlt.
Doch, ich wette mit
euch, mir fehlt es dort an was.
Und zwar
an einem eigenen
Linux-Laptop.
Haben die bestimmt nicht.
Die Möglichkeit, dich beruflich und persönlich
auf eine hohe Ebene zu entfalten... Was?
auf einer hohen Ebene zu
entfalten.
What?
Wie entfalte ich mich? Also, okay.
Ich muss verbindlich
aufdrehen, um mich auf einer hohen Ebene
zu entfalten. Alles klar.
Das ist einfach nur Filler, ja.
Glaube auch.
Eine Vielzahl an Benefits und Zusatzangeboten
im Europapark.
The fuck?
Ist ja schön und gut, dass ich in den Europapark fahren kann,
aber ich kann auch selbst
in den Europapark fahren, wenn ihr mir genug Kohle
bezahlt.
Ach, Moment!
Das ist ein Job im Europapark.
Das habe ich gar nicht gecheckt.
Okay, dann ergibt es natürlich Sinn.
Profitiere von
erstklassigen Trainings
und Fachseminaren.
Fuck. Academy.
Ja, auch
sehr 0815-ige
Stellenanzeige.
Jetzt nicht super toll, nicht super
schlecht. Standard.
Jetzt nix drinnen, wo ich gleich
sagen würde, boah, nee, bloß nicht.
Standard-Kram.
Sticht nicht groß hier raus.
Aber sonst noch.
Oh, die sehen aber hip aus.
Die müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Die sehen ja mal sowas von hipster-modern aus.
Bank 11.
Was zum Teufel ist Bank 11?
Äh.
Ist das...
Okay, das ist ein bisschen so wie Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof,
nur seriöser.
Mit Geldleihen.
Okay, also.
Für alle? Für euch.
Ja, natürlich. Ihr sagt mir, macht das
alles nur aus reiner Nächstenliebe, ist klar.
Das ist für die
Leute nach dem Insi-Modus.
Genau.
Aber immerhin,
eins muss man ihnen lassen,
sie haben recht fähige
so
Gestaltungsleute.
Ich meine, das sind irgendwelche Stockfotos,
das sind keine Leute, die irgendwie auch nur annähern,
was mit der Bank dazu, oder das ist ja nicht mal eine Bank,
oder? Mit diesem
Dienstleister da zu tun haben.
Aber immerhin, es hat eine gewisse,
auch wenn man das jetzt hier mehr Dark-Reader ausmacht,
es hat zumindest irgendwie eine gewisse
Identität, die Seite.
Das ist schon ganz okay.
Die Gesichter sind auch viel größer,
die sind so glücklich, dass sie da sind.
Und sie können auch sehr gut sein.
Achso.
Ja, die können auch sehr gut sein.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Ne, die kommen.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Nicht irgendwie auf den Bahamas oder so.
Immerhin.
Also, was wollen sie haben? Sie wollen einen DevOps-Engineer haben.
Für alle, für euch,
schnell, schlau und digital.
Möchtest du die digitale Welt
von morgen erobern?
Ja, unbedingt.
Zu deinen
Stärken zählen ein Kundenorientierungssystem,
das ist ja auch, Moment,
aber nicht verbindlich, ne?
Und es ist auch die Frage,
ob man sich da auf der höchsten Ebene
entfalten kann.
Also, die in der letzten Stellenanzeige stand,
war schon ein bisschen viel
Filler-Text drin.
Und strukturiertes und selbstständiges Arbeiten.
Dann kommen jetzt zur Bank 11.
Oder ist es
vielleicht sogar Bank 11?
Eine der besten Autobanken
Deutschlands mit über 400
MitarbeiterInnen.
Bei uns hast du die Möglichkeit,
IT-Lösungen mit und weiter zu entwickeln
und Impulse zu setzen in einem
engagierten, achtköpfigen,
ganze acht Leute, achso, naja, gut,
es wird nicht die einzige IT-Abteilung dort sein.
Oder Team
in der IT-Abteilung.
Was ist eine Autobank? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Sie suchen einen DevOps-Engineer,
also quasi, die, mal gucken,
das wird ja was, was genau auf mich passt.
Das heißt, das müsste mich ansprechen.
Deine spannenden Aufgaben
mit Betreuung der operativen
Projekte und deren Entwicklung.
Bereitstellung, gemeinsame Weiterentwicklung
unserer Continuous Delivery Pipeline
sowie der Cloud-Umgebung, ja, passt gut dazu.
Unterstütz-, Unterstützung beim Betrieb
unserer bestehenden Infrastruktur in eine, ja,
ja, gut, es ist Business Enterprise.
Und gerade im Finanzdienstleister-Umfeld
ist Java super etabliert, ja.
Unsere bestehende Infrastruktur in einer Java-basierten
Multi-Tier-Umgebung.
Was auch immer das in dem Kontext bedeutet.
Dass sie mehrere, Multi-Tier,
damit ist ja normalerweise gemeint,
du kannst da verschiedene Clients drin anlegen
und sowas, aber, oder meinen die mit
Multi-Tier-Umgebung, dass du verschiedene
Umgebungs-Stages hast, sowas wie
Test und
Integration oder so
und Live und
ich weiß es nicht,
Dokumentation der operativen Prozesse,
schon wieder!
Leute, ich, ich, es wird echt
langsam Zeit für das Wubblos-Zertifikat.
Was die immer alle mit,
mit ihrer Dokumentation, weil das meint ja,
wie viel Geld man damit sparen könnte, wenn die alle das
äh, den, den, den,
den, die Wubblos-Skalierung,
Skalierungsmethode
verwenden würden.
Teilnahme an Release-Prozessen.
Warum wird denn das so fett geschrieben?
Meinen die damit, nachts wird deployed
und du musst dabei sein?
Das lese ich jetzt hier nicht raus,
aber kann damit gemeint sein?
Projektsprache ist Deutsch!
Bäm!
Erste Praxiserfahrung,
mit Linux-Systemen.
Ja, und das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt in dem Umfeld.
So wie im DevOps-Umfeld Java-Anwendung auf Spring Boot
Docker Elastic Stack.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie tatsächlich
produktive Sachen mit Docker laufen haben.
Nicht, dass man das nicht machen könnte, aber
vielleicht nicht zwangsläufig die beste Idee.
Aber kann man machen.
Gerade wenn man nicht so viel Infrastruktur hat
und es nicht sonderlich hoch verfügbar sein muss, dann
ja,
ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es
irgendein Managed Kubernetes ist
bei irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter,
wo es dann am Ende drin läuft.
Ja, Elasticsearch.
Wie heißt das ganze Zeug da bei Elasticsearch?
Das besteht doch aus mehreren Teilen.
Ich vergesse aber, wie das heißt.
Es ist nicht nur Elasticsearch,
es ist noch, ähm,
Kibana? Kibana, genau.
Kibana?
Ist das der Elk-Stack? Elasticsearch?
Kibana? Und was ist das? El?
Logstash?
Genau, ja.
Das ist der Chat. Chat. Es
gab einfach schon zu viele Prime-Subs
heute. Der Chat
hat zu viel Gehirn.
Natürlich kann man nie zu viel Gehirn haben.
Radiant Tracer, danke für den Sub.
Sorry, falls ich übersehen habe. Schon zwei Stunden
her. Keck, wait.
SikJuicySJ
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Jetzt ist...
Megamind, ja.
Der Chat ist einfach zu schlau
für Twitch. Also jetzt mal ohne Mist,
gell? Wenn ich auf Twitch so unterwegs
bin und mir da die anderen Sachen angucke,
muss ich schon ehrlich sagen, ihr seid mit
Sicherheit
vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt
der most high IQ Chat,
aber auf jeden Fall Top 5%
high IQ Chat auf Twitch.
FourYearOldChinese
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pfeiffer Chat.
Biolite. Pog Subscription,
Dankeschön. Oh Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob ich
das heute alles schaffe. Ich habe noch so viel auf.
Ich habe noch so viel Zeit. Reicht jetzt für heute.
Hebt euch für den nächsten Stream auf.
Ihr könnt das übrigens auch in normalen Streams posten,
sowas zwischendurch angucken kann man immer machen.
Okay, also was haben wir sonst noch? Praxiserfahrung
im Linux-System?
DevOps umfällig, Ava, Springboot, Lasswin.
Erste Kenntnisse, zum Beispiel im Bereich
Container Delivery Prozesse,
okay, die machen Gitlab, äh, ne,
Gitlab CI heißt es nicht,
Gibt's nicht.
Es gibt Hub Actions und GitLab CI.
Ähm, IT-Security, Konfigur...
Was? Und, oder...
Configuration API.
What?
Das hat jemand geschrieben, der nicht weiß, was er da schreibt, glaube ich.
Was ist Configuration API?
Was soll das in diesem Kontext bedeuten?
Da steht...
IT-Security.
Anzeige.
Abmahnung.
Kenntnis in einer Konfigurationsmanagement-Software wie zum Beispiel Terraform sind von Vorteil.
Terraform ist auch das Einzige, was Sinn macht.
Einfach mit Abstand das Verbreitetste.
Hat die meisten Plugins, unterstützt die meisten Provider.
Und ist ganz passabel eigentlich auch zu benutzen.
Wenn's mich auch regelmäßig abfuckt, aber das würden wahrscheinlich andere Lösungen auch.
Ich würde ja gerne mal ein bisschen mehr Crossplane ausprobieren.
Aber das ist quasi Terraform für Kubernetes, um es mal ganz in einem Satz zu sagen.
Trifft's nicht genau, aber...
Dass ihr euch was so nach vorstellen könnt.
Ich würde ja mal gerne ein bisschen Crossplane ausprobieren.
Was mich ein bisschen abschreckt ist, das scheint mir einen super krassen Einstiegs-Lernkurve zu haben.
Und es hat irgendwie so eine ganz komische Philosophie, dass Änderungen ohne jegliche Prüfung immer sofort angewandt werden.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen, die sind Wubbler-Certifizierte.
Weil wenn man keine Fehler in den Änderungen drin hat, dann können die auch immer sofort so applied werden.
Weil dann ist ja alles immer richtig.
Vielleicht machen die es auch einfach nur korrekt.
Du kannst ja auch mal...
Was?
Hückel.
Das ist...
Das ist das Apple-Ding, ja?
Interesse an Container- und Cloud-Technologien.
Abgeschlossene Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker oder vergleichbare Qualifikation.
Leistungsgereiche Urlaubstage, mobiles Arbeiten, Altersvorsorge, Kinder...
Irgendwas nicht verkehrt.
Viele Aktionen, Vergünstigungen mit unserem Bistro-Getränk.
Und das ist immer nice, wenn es dort vor Ort was zu fressen gibt.
Sehr nice.
Schnell, schlau, digital.
Welcome LGBTQ und BIPOC.
Okay, jetzt hört aber meine Kenntnis auf.
Da kann ich mir nur was darunter vorstellen.
Aber was ist BIPOC?
Oder BIPOC?
Black?
Vielleicht?
Indigene People of Color.
Aha.
Okay.
Das ist nicht neu.
Mag sein.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also...
Langsam ist auch mal gut mit Abkürzungen, ja.
Ich hätte auch gerne eigene Abkürzungen.
Was ist IT-interessiertes Kellerkind?
Kann man da auch irgendwas dafür machen?
Ich mach was mit Computer.
Das braucht auch eine eigene Abkürzung.
Ja, das eh.
Das...
Hä?
Warum wird das gar nicht gepostet?
Alter, das...
Das...
Twitch blockt das mittlerweile.
Guck mal.
Twitch hat das mittlerweile geblockt.
Du bist ein alter, weißer Mann.
Das muss sich eben erst explizit freigeben.
Ja, ist auch so.
Ja, ja.
Das musste sich eben explizit freigeben.
Es ist noch schlimmer, Leute.
Es ist noch schlimmer.
Ich bin alt.
Weiß.
Männlich.
Heterosexuell.
Kein Veganer.
Also Omnivore, wie man das so schön nennt.
Ähm...
Was bin ich denn noch?
Was eigentlich ganz furchtbar schlimm ist heutzutage.
Deutsch auch noch, ja?
Nee, blond bin ich nicht.
Privilegiert.
Stimmt, ich hab auch noch...
Fuck, ich hab auch noch ein Haus, Mann.
Nicht sportlich.
Da wär ich mir aber nicht so sicher.
Tesla-Fahrer.
Nein, nein, nein.
Tesla-Fahrer nicht.
Aber eh...
Aber Elektro-Auto-Fahrer.
Das stimmt.
Blaue Augen.
Nee, auch nicht.
Aber das ist...
Das ist Prof...
Also, das ist...
Das ich ein Elektro-Auto habe, ist glaube ich das Einzige, was ich auf der Pro-Seite hab, oder?
Alles andere ist ja heute so negativ vorbelastet.
Bei manchen Leuten, ja.
Man könnte auch einfach sagen, das andere ist einfach normal.
Boah.
Äh...
Ich hab keinen extra Stromanbieter.
Ich hab keinen extra Stromanbieter für die Wallbox.
Gut, also, weiter.
Also, ich find die Stellenanzeige nicht verkehrt.
Der Inhalt, und das muss man ja bei vielen Stellenanzeigen, jetzt muss man ja schon mal loben, hervorheben.
Der Inhalt deckt sich mit dem, zumindest zum größten Teil, was ich mir unter dieser Berufsbezeichnung vorstellen würde.
Das ist ja schon mal was.
Ich find das nicht verkehrt.
Dass da Rechtschreibfehler in der Stellenanzeige sind, so, Wort, mich juckt's jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich könnte natürlich schon da reininterpretieren, vielleicht bisschen so lack of...
...Qualitätssicherung.
Das war auch ein Satz, oder?
Lack of Qualitätssicherung.
Ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Arbeitstage Montag bis Freitag.
Ja.
Ich denke, das ist gar nicht so übel hier.
Ob die natürlich nicht so übel bezahlen, das weiß ich nicht.
Was haben wir da als nächstes?
Wir müssen jetzt mal von dort anfangen, weil die warten schon ganz lange hier, die Leute.
Das bei Amazon guck ich mir jetzt nicht an.
DevOps Engineer Systematik.
Systemadministrator.
Das sind nämlich die Sachen, die ganz am Anfang vom Stream gepostet wurden.
DemV Systems.
DevOps Engineer Systemadministrator MWD in Hamburg oder Remote.
Stimmt, die brauchen wir ja, wissen wir auch noch.
Aber wir haben noch Zeit.
Also, sie suchen...
Ja.
Find ich okay.
Weil ganz ehrlich, die meisten DevOps-Leute kommen aus dem Bereich und das hat viele Überschneidungen.
Also, ich kenn mehr DevOps-Leute, die aus dem Bereich kommen.
Als ehemalige Anwendungsentwickler, die das jetzt machen.
Außerdem, DevOps ist im Prinzip der neue Admin.
Klingt einfach cooler.
So, als DevOps Engineer bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Du optimierst und hältst unsere Server-Infrastruktur auf dem neuesten Stand.
Das ist nice.
Das ist genau das, was ich mir darunter vorstelle.
DevOps ist halt kein Ausbildungsberuf.
Ja, Systemadministrator auch nicht.
Du kannst im Prinzip Fachinformatiker für Systementwicklung machen.
Das ist cool.
Das ist einfach das, was ich mir darunter vorstelle.
DevOps ist halt kein Ausbildungsberuf.
Ja, Systemadministrator auch nicht.
Du kannst im Prinzip Fachinformatiker für Systementwicklung machen.
Das ist kein Ausbildungsberuf.
Optimal, ehrlich gesagt, war ich als
Aber!
Verste לכlamierung?
Throwable?
Hm.
ist keine gute Idee mehr heutzutage.
Seriously, du findest immer schwieriger
Leute, die Puppet-Erfahrung
haben.
Also Puppet findest du
sehr schwer, Ansible findest du
deutlich mehr. Nicht wie Sand am Meer,
aber deutlich mehr.
Natürlich haben die das Problem,
die haben bestimmt ihre gesamte Infrastruktur in Puppet
am Start, aber es ist
wirklich schwierig, da Leute zu finden, Leute.
Durch das Zusammenspiel
von Monitoring und Alerting
sorgst du für eine hohe
Verfügbarkeit und schnelle Problemerkennung.
Du integrierst
Software in unsere Multi-Cloud-Umgebung.
Bei Hetzner und AWS, aha, nice.
Das ist doch mal eine sinnvolle
Kombination, muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Du machst
bei AWS, wenn du irgendwie
einen der tausend Managed Sachen
dort brauchst, wenn du einfach
nur eine simple VM brauchst,
mit
vielleicht einem Loadbalancer davor,
machst du Hetzner.
Da bist du mit Sicherheit
auch eine ganze Ecke billiger
dabei.
Ich schick den, ja genau,
schick den in Bewerbung den Rabattcode mit.
Das wär's jetzt mal.
Also,
ich sag's jetzt nochmal,
ich öfters da gefragt werde, ich such kein Job
aktuell, das ist just for fun hier.
Infrastructure as Code,
setzt du via Terraform um? Genau.
Das ist gut. Einzig sinnvolle
Tool dafür. Also, es gibt schon noch mehr,
aber das mit Abstand verpassen,
breitetste und bekannteste
ist Terraform.
Zusammen mit den Teams entwickelst du neue
Services und Projekte.
Okay. Du hast
ein Stück, okay, blablabla,
mit Linux, insbesondere Debian
kommst du gut zurecht. Pluspunkt, Leute,
Pluspunkt. Die setzen eine ordentliche
Distribution ein und es kommt nicht einmal
Windows und Microsoft
Shit in dieser Stellenanzeige vor. Sehr
nice.
Shit und Shit Hub
sowie
CICD via GitHub Actions,
auch nice, auch nice. Ja, finde ich
cool. Was die GitHub Actions
benutzen. Ich mag GitHub Actions.
Von allen
Systemen,
die ich bisher benutzt habe, was
so Automatisierungsbildgeschichten
angeht, finde ich
GitHub Actions am angenehmsten.
Ich hab natürlich auch bei weitem
nicht alles ausprobiert. Ich kenn
den Klassiker, ich kenn sowas wie Jenkins,
ich kenn GitLab CI und ich kenn
GitHub Actions.
Und ich glaube, das war es.
Und da muss ich sagen, so von
dem Gesamtpaket finde ich
GitHub Actions einfach am schönsten.
Container, insbesondere Docker,
sind bei uns immer mehr im Einsatz.
Konfiguration, Puppet,
Englisch,
wenn du dich mit MariaDB
auskennst, ist das ein Pluspunkt, aber
ja,
mich persönlich spricht das hier an.
Wo sind die? Hamburg.
Ob natürlich jetzt der Laden
wirklich gut ist, ob das
halt taugt, so keine Ahnung.
Also mich würden diese
Parts hier durchaus ansprechen.
AWS ist die Cloud-Umgebung
oder der, sorry Leute, nicht
Cloud-Anbieter. Ich muss ja
meinen eigenen, meinem eigenen Advice
folgen.
Hyperscaler.
AWS ist der Hyperscaler, mit dem
ich mich am wenigsten auskenne.
Azure kenn ich mich ganz gut aus.
Google kenn ich mich mittlerweile sogar besser aus,
weil ich das letzte Jahr über
AWS, Azure hab ich schon wieder jede Menge vergessen.
Ähm,
Kugel mach ich das letzte Jahr über täglich.
Google Cloud.
AWS kenn ich mich am wenigsten mit aus.
Bei den drei großen
Hyperscalern. Auch ein
Rechtschreibfehler, echt, wo denn?
Also mich spricht's an.
Auch no bullshit, kurz und
knackig, alles gut.
Könnt mir nur noch toppen,
aber ich könnte da einiges noch toppen, aber
eine Sache wär natürlich gut, wenn gleich mal drinnen
stehen würde, wie viel Kohle man erwarten kann.
Hast du eine Empfehlung?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hast du eine Empfehlung, wie man als Dev am besten in Cloud-Themen einsteigt?
Ja.
Bau Docker-Container.
Erstmal unabhängig von Cloud.
Bau mal Docker-Container, containerisiere mal deine Anwendung.
Da lernst du sehr viel dabei.
Was dir auch später was bringt, wenn das denn beispielsweise mal in irgendeinem Managed Kubernetes läuft oder so.
Containerisiere mal deine eigene Anwendung.
Und zwar gescheit, ja?
Also nicht, dass da ein 600 MB großes Image rauskommt, sondern ein Multistage-Bild, das am Ende wirklich nur ein Image rauskommt, was keine Ahnung, minimal slim Debian ist, kein Alpine, ich persönlich bin kein Alpine-Fan, hab ich schon oft genug gesagt.
Ich finde, auf die paar MBs kommt's dann auch nicht an.
20 MB, 30 MB großes Image, geht so bestimmt auch kleiner.
Containerisiere mal deine Anwendung.
Das ist ein guter Einstiegspunkt.
Hat das nicht direkt was mit Cloud?
Mit Cloud zu tun ist aber Voraussetzung für viele Sachen in der Cloud.
Und ansonsten musst du dich ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigen, weil das meiste in der Cloud ist Linux-based.
Nicht, dass es kein Windows gibt, aber glücklicherweise machen die Leute da einen größeren Bogen drum.
Wie lernt man am besten Kubernetes einfach mal machen?
Minikube.
Minikube ist mit Abstand das Einfachste.
Start.
Und schon hast du ein Kubernetes zum Basteln lokal laufen auf deiner Kiste.
Das geht auch nur unter Linux, by the way.
Ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr gestartet, deswegen lädt das ja erstmal den ganzen Shit runter.
Arch, by the way.
Aber das geht auch unter anderem Linux-Distribution, das muss nicht unbedingt Arch sein.
Geht bestimmt auch unter Gentoo irgendwie nach zwei Stunden kompilieren.
Guck hier, zack.
Jetzt hat er die neuesten Kubernetes-Sachen runtergeladen.
Jetzt erstellt er einen Container mit der Kubernetes-Control-Plane.
Und wenn das dann irgendwann mal gestartet ist.
Minikube ist auf Windows, ja, auf Windows mit VM-Backend wahrscheinlich dann, ja.
Und jetzt kannst du sagen, kubectl get pods-a.
Und siehst du, hast du einen lokalen Kubernetes-Cluster, der noch am Starten ist, aber du hast einen lokalen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Und kannst jetzt damit rumbasteln.
Was du damit nicht ausprobieren kannst, sind natürlich irgendwelche Cloud-Anbieterspiele.
Spezifischen Sachen oder irgendwelche, ja, wo es wirklich um hochverfügbare Sachen geht mit Rolling-Updates über mehrere Nodes und sowas.
Da brauchst du was anderes für.
Aber um mal so die grundsätzlichen Sachen dir anzugucken und damit auch mal was drauf zu deployen und so.
Minikube.
Tomox, das kann ich dir auch empfehlen.
Minikube, beste.
Und wenn du fertig bist, sagst du Minikube, deleten, ist wieder alles rückstandslos weg.
So.
Also.
Eins, eins war mal noch hier.
Wo ist hier?
Ja.
Für unsere Fußball-Stelz, Leute.
Boah, mein Auge.
Das ist ein...
Leute.
Der Hintergrund, das ist kein weißer Hintergrund, das ist ein weißes Bild im Hintergrund.
Deswegen funktioniert der Dark-Reader da nicht drauf.
Painstchamp, Alter.
IT-Systemadministration, äh, Administrator, System-Engineer, Schwerpunkt IT-Security.
Ein Weg, ein Ziel, eine Leidenschaft.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Das ist ein Bild, oder?
Oder auch nicht?
Ja, doch, das ist ein Bild, oder?
Wir haben eine über hundertjährige Tradition.
Ja, Fußball halt.
Du fungierst als erster Ansprechpartner für IT-Security.
Du steu...
Moment.
Du fungierst als erster Ansprechpartner für unsere IT-Security-Partner.
Hä?
Ach, für irgendwelche Pentester-Dudes und sowas, hä?
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Du steuerst die Zusammenarbeit mit unserem Extern Security Operation Center.
Hä?
Dann verstehe ich die Stelle auch nicht so ganz.
Du bist an Konzeption, Weiterentwicklung sowie Umsetzung Schutz...
Einsatzbereitschaft an Heimspieltagen unserer Mannschaft.
Was?
Meinen die damit, ich muss Fußballfan sein und mir das angucken?
Oder meinen die, ich habe Bereitschaft, falls was kaputt geht an Heimspieltagen?
Ich verstehe nicht genau, was sie damit meinen.
Du musst Würstchen verkaufen.
Mehrjährige Berufserfahrung als IT-Administrator.
Du bist ein Allround-Talent innerhalb der IT.
Idealerweise...
Man nennt sowas heute übrigens nicht mehr Allround-Talent.
Ich habe letztens auch gehört, dass man als Buzzword da heutzutage verwendet...
Check of all trades.
Weil Allround-Talent klingt zu nubisch.
Es gibt für jeden Kack irgendwelche Wörter mittlerweile.
Idealerweise...
Idealerweise bringst du gute Kenntnisse im IT-Security-Umfeld.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist Pflicht, oder?
Als IT-Administrativ-Schwerpunkt-Security.
Das Ding ist halt...
Das ist halt super umfangreich.
Was genau wollt ihr denn von mir?
Also, sinnbildlich gesprochen, nicht direkt von mir persönlich jetzt.
Was wollt ihr denn von dem Bewerber?
IT-Security-Umfeld.
Ey, ich habe mal mit Nmap ein paar Server gescannt.
Ja.
Gute Kenntnisse im IT-Security-Umfeld.
Fundierte Kenntnisse von verschiedenen IT-Security-Tools.
Ich kann einen Curl machen.
Leistungsorientiertes und userzentriertes Denken und Handeln.
Gute Kenntnisse in Collaboration-Tools.
Ja, welche denn?
Es gibt ja nur eins auf der Welt.
Und wenn ich das kenne, ist es gut.
Kommunikationsstärke, Teamfähigkeit, Verantwortungsbewusstsein.
Eine interessante, vielseitige Tätigkeit.
Gutes Arbeitsklima mit einem dynamischen Umfeld.
Mit motivierten, sympathischen Kollegen.
Bereitstellung von Kosten.
Kostenfreien Getränken.
Freikarte für Heimspiel.
Okay, für Fußballfans ist es bestimmt mega nice.
Vergünstigung in der...
In der was?
Fohlens...
Fohlen...
Fohlensportsbar.
Fanshop-Rabatte.
Vergünstigtes Fahrrad-Leasing-Betriebe-Camp.
Hybrides Arbeiten.
Ey, ich glaube für Fußballfans bestimmt nice.
Für mich sind ein bisschen wenig Details drin.
Das sind so...
Einfach mal so ein paar Dinger hingeschrieben.
Collaboration-Tools.
IT-Security-Umfeld.
Ja, was genau stellt ihr euch denn vor?
Ein bisschen spezifischer darf es schon sein.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Mich spricht es jetzt nicht so an.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Vielleicht für die krassen Fußballfans unter euch.
Du wolltest doch was mit C-Sharp-Globale-Variablen zeigen.
Ne, das wollte ich nur zeigen, wenn derjenige, der das gefragt hat, das letzte Mal wieder da ist.
Und bis jetzt war er noch nicht wieder da.
Oder bist du das gewesen?
Meinst du?
Ne.
Ne, das zeige ich, wenn derjenige, der das gefragt hat, da ist.
Oder willst du noch jemanden wissen?
Ne, macht ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich das jetzt zeige und er nicht da ist.
Ihr benutzt Jyra, ja?
Ich bin auch ein großer Jyra-Fan.
Leon-Pock-Subscription.
Ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Die hatten wir schon.
Okay, eine können wir uns noch angucken.
Welche gucken wir uns noch an?
Was gucken wir uns denn an?
Stadt-Essen.
Okay, die sind immer lustig, meistens.
So öffentliche Sachen.
Was entscheidest du eigentlich, was in welchem Browser gemacht wird?
Intuitiv, spontan.
Webex, Paints-Champ.
Elf-TV, das war nicht so viel, gell?
Wir gucken da jedes Mal nach und stellen immer fest, das ist nicht so nice.
Schwerpunkt-Security.
Okay, die Stadt-Essen.
Was ist denn das da vorne eigentlich?
Das sieht aus wie Haverschmittel.
So Shampoo, aber was ist das?
Was sehe ich da?
Nee, für Textmarker ist es doch viel zu groß.
Oder ist es einfach nur Perspektive?
Perspektive, das Lieblingswort aller Flacherdler.
Perspektive.
Was sind Textmarker?
Ganz schön fette Textmarker, oder?
Ja, ein bisschen zu kleines Fop.
Tatsächlich, die sind das.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Okay, Teilzeit gehabt.
Das ESH, das was?
Essen, ja, Systemhaus.
Ist als eigenes, okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Mit ihrem Einsatz werden sie unsere Abteilung Rechenzentrumsbetrieb.
Die mit ihren Teams gemeinsam, Rechenzentrum, Server, Datenbank, Dienst und Bürokommunikation.
Okay, also einfach für alles, ja?
Rechenzentrum, Server, Datenbank, Dienst und Bürokommunikation.
Also einfach alles.
Ihr zukünftiger Arbeitsort befindet sich im ETC-Karree und dem angrenzenden Gebäude.
Wen juckt's?
Ja, dich hätten wir heute öfter schon gebraucht bei den ganzen Intros der Stellenanzeigen.
Sie verstärken die Abteilung Rechenzentrumsbetrieb bei diesen Aufgaben.
Okay, Administration und Weiterentwicklung von komplexen IT-Sekunden im Bereich Endpoint Protection.
Aha.
Any 7 TV-Mods?
Die Mode am Start.
Das ist nice.
Ja, das klingt super allgemein.
Endpoint Protection.
Alles ist irgendwie ein Endpoint, der protected werden muss.
Proaktives Monitoring.
Bewertung von IT-Security-Vorfällen sowie Initierung von Gegenmaßnahmen.
Ja, das braucht die Stadt Essen tatsächlich.
Gab's da nicht vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal richtig Probleme, gerade auch bei der Stadt Essen?
Mit irgendwelchen Ransomware-Trojaner-Geschiss?
Da war doch irgendwas.
Ja, ich bekomme da auch keine Vibes bei der Stellenanzeige.
Zusammenarbeit mit prozessvoranschlägigen Endbenutzern zur Erarbeitung von Verbesserungsoptionen in bestehenden Infrastrukturen.
Das ist super allgemein alles.
Abgeschlossener Verwaltungslehrgang 2 mit dem Schwerpunkt IT.
Okay.
Damit fallen schon mal 99,9% oder 99,99% der Leute, die dafür in Frage kommen, raus.
Wer zum Teufel hat einen abgeschlossenen Verwaltungslehrgang 2?
Wenn du nicht gerade schon zufällig dort irgendwie gearbeitet hast und eigentlich nur intern wechseln willst.
Damit werde ich halt einfach keine Leute finden.
Fachkenntnisse.
In der Sistieradministration im Bereich Betriebssysteme, Windows, Linux, Protokolle, Netzwerkinfrastruktur.
Wer hat denn diesen, wer schreibt denn diesen Scheiß immer, Mann?
In Windows, Linux lasse ich mir noch gefallen, in einer Person.
Ah, Protokolle, Mann.
Was jetzt?
Wer schreibt diesen Scheiß immer?
Das ist so schlecht, Mann.
Kein Wunder, dass die keine Leute finden.
Und wenn sie Leute finden, keine fähigen Leute, da wunderst du dich echt nicht mehr.
Was das jetzt mit dem Titel zu tun hat?
Naja, Systemadministrator, dann musst du dich mit Protokollen, mit allen Protokollen, muss ich auskennen.
Kenntnisse im Bereich Security, Endpoint Protection, EDR und XDR.
Okay, da haben sie mich jetzt erwischt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür EDR steht.
EDR? Könnte das auch für Endpoint Protection stehen?
Endpoint Protection?
Ah, Moment, Endpoint Detection and Response.
Alles klar.
Und was ist XDR?
XD-ing.
XD.
Extended Detection and Response.
Ah, ein Holistic Security Solution, alles klar.
Auf Deutsch heißt das, Holistic bedeutet sowas wie ganzheitlich.
Aber Holistic Approach klingt natürlich viel,
aber Holistic Approach klingt natürlich viel, aber Holistic Approach klingt natürlich viel,
weil воод sei was der nochmal geiler.
ry
Geiler.
Sch başsrenchen, und aplikationsmanagement.
Beziehungsweise die Bereitschaft diese kurzfristig zu erwerben
fruit.
Jetzt Particularly.
Ganz ehrlich.
Moment, Moment, hahaha, jebaited, jebaited, overrated, outdated, das ist ja diese Steige, das geht aber eigentlich schon mal ganz gut, ganz gut klar, oder, je nachdem wie das mit den Steuern ist und, wobei das Aufsteigen, das ist ja immer so ganz komisch, du musst mindestens ein Jahr haben, dann musst du hier alles das, was du davor hast, plus das, plus das, plus das, also nach 5 Jahren in Stufe 5,
das erreichst du irgendwie nach 20 Jahren dort, oder so, ich kann, ich kann diese öffentlichen Sachen immer sehr schlecht, sehr schlecht einschätzen, wie gut und schlecht das ist, sind es 12 Gehälter, 13, 14, wenn es nur 12 sind, ist das jetzt sicherlich nicht geil,
das sind dann, das ist jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn, das ist schon besser, aber auch nicht so wahnsinnig doll,
das könnte es ja nicht sein,
du musst halt rausreißen, wenn du nicht so viele Steuern bezahlen musst, weiß ich nicht, wie das da ist, also, aber selbst, selbst mal 13 ist nicht so krass jetzt, ja, also, ich kann das immer, ich kann das immer schwer einschätzen, wahrscheinlich ist der, ist die, also, das hier ist auf jeden Fall nicht geil, brauchst du ein Studium, nee, brauchst du nicht, tut auch das hier, so, ohne Beamtung, ja, okay, dann bezahlst du ganz normal Steuern, ja, Stufenaufstieg ist automatisch nach 12 Monaten,
aber,
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe,
ähm,
funktioniert das ja folgendermaßen,
du steigst automatisch nach 12,
du steigst automatisch auf,
nach einem Jahr hierin,
okay,
dann musst du quasi 3 Jahre
da drin haben,
also, nee, da musst du 3 Jahre,
da musst du 3 Jahre darin haben,
da musst du 3 Jahre
da drin sein, also, das addiert sich,
also, am Ende,
musst du da irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre oder so dabei sein,
dass du, dass du da irgendwo landest,
und in 15 Jahren ist das halt auch nicht mehr geil,
und jetzt auch schon nicht so wahnsinnig
voll,
also, reich wirst du da nicht von,
das liest sich, wieso, steht doch da,
du steigst automatisch nach dem ersten Jahr auf,
da rein, so,
dann brauchst du mindestens 3 Jahre, das da,
okay, vielleicht kannst du auch direkt da drin einsteigen,
aber spätestens hier,
und da fängt es dann langsam mal interessant zu werden,
musst du mindestens 3 Jahre,
das da haben,
danach musst du mindestens 4 Jahre, das da haben,
und danach musst du mindestens 5 Jahre, das da haben,
also, das addiert sich dann auf jeden Fall zusammen,
das heißt, du kommst dann hier schon mal auf 12 Jahre,
musst mindestens 12 Jahre dabei sein,
dass es ganz brauchbar ist, was rauskommt,
weil, selbst das ist jetzt nicht super,
irgendwie, Advanced,
Gas, Kohle,
für,
in 12 Jahren,
okay,
aber ganz davon abgesehen,
das ist nicht netto,
nein, da musst du noch Steuern drauf bezahlen,
netto wäre das nice,
ist es aber nicht,
naja, warum,
6000 Euro netto, kannst du dich nicht beschweren,
ich weiß nicht, was der Chat für Anforderungen hat,
aber das fände ich okay,
und selbst 4000 Euro netto ist sicherlich nicht schlecht,
das ist ungefähr,
ungefähr das,
was ich,
mit 4 Tage Woche verdiene im Monat,
ungefähr,
also, was ungefähr mit 4 Tage Woche und,
Berufsbereitschaft, bei mir im Monat auf dem Konto ankommt,
da ist aber der Bonus noch nicht dabei,
also, das ist jetzt,
und,
ich verdiene nicht schlecht, also,
das ist schon in Ordnung,
wenn, wenn es das wäre,
kannst du nichts sagen,
also, da hat wahrscheinlich,
die meisten Leute in Deutschland weniger,
also, Nico, da kann man sich, finde ich, finde ich, echt in Ordnung,
Finanzen sagt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist,
ja, es ist ungefähr in dem Dreh,
es sind,
ich müsste jetzt in die App gucken,
es sind irgendwie 3400 Euro,
plus, die Berufsbereitschaftssachen,
da kommt halt noch immer ganz viel Kleinscheiß dabei,
also, es ist wahrscheinlich ein,
Mini, also, mit Bonus ist es auf jeden Fall mehr, aber wahrscheinlich ist es,
ich weiß es nicht, ich müsste jetzt, ich müsste jetzt bei mir in der, in der App gucken,
ich müsste vor allem mal wieder,
ordentliche Zeiterfassung machen, für meine Berufsbereitschaft, dass ich die Kohle auch bekomme,
hat ein Arbeitgeber noch, ja, das ist ein riesengroßer Laden,
riesengroße Versicherung in Frankfurt,
mit zig, zig, ähm,
Standorten in Deutschland,
aber, ganz ehrlich, die Stellenanzeige,
hier ist Schrott,
würde ich mich nie im Leben darauf bewerben,
richtig Schrott,
wer das immer schreibt, bei den Behörden, weiß auch nicht,
die müssen sich wirklich nicht wundern, dass die keine Leute finden,
wie gesagt, wenn sie Leute finden, dann finden sie keine fähigen Leute,
dann haben sie demnächst wieder,
Ransomware-Verschlüsselungs-
Gramm,
ähm,
Bettke, richtig,
jetzt ist,
Bettke-Time angesagt,
was ist deine Meinung,
nach die,
best,
Moment, ich, Moment, ich geh noch nicht ins Bett, ich muss eben, irgendwas wollte ich oben noch,
noch auf irgendwas oben eingehen,
muss gleich nochmal durchcrollen,
was sind deiner Meinung nach die bestbezahlten IT-Jobs, wo es auch wirklich viele von gibt,
AI-Engineer, das ist ja aktuell jetzt noch nicht das Mainstream-Ding, ja,
Cloud-Engineer, Projektleiter, Solution-Architekt,
keine Ahnung,
da musst du dir irgendwelche Statistik-Seiten angucken,
Heiser hat jedes Jahr sowas,
äh, Stack-Overflow hat auch ne Umfrage,
das weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf, keine Ahnung,
ganz ehrlich, ich würd nicht danach gehen, was der bestbezahlte Job ist,
ich würd mir was suchen in dem Bereich, auf den ich Bock hab,
du kannst in jedem IT-Bereich gut Kohle verdienen,
wenn du Ahnung davon hast, wenn du was kannst, was,
eben,
gebraucht wird und was nicht viele Leute können,
und das heißt,
meistens nicht,
ich kann mich mal auf Windows, auf dem Linux-System einloggen und drei Befehle eintippen,
oder ich kann in Windows drei Sachen klicken,
sondern,
du hast wirklich tiefgreifend Ahnung von irgendwas,
ah, gut, SAP ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken, das stimmt,
und die Chance, dass du tiefgreifend von was Ahnung hast,
vielleicht auch nach ein paar Jahren, ist,
umso höher, wenn das was ist, was dich persönlich interessiert,
weil nur dann lernst du ordentlich was,
und nur dann fällt es dir leicht, Sachen da drin zu lernen,
und,
umso besser sind dann auch die Chancen da drin,
da vorne zu arbeiten,
und umso besser sind dann auch die Chancen dort,
sagen wir mal, eine,
ein bisschen,
advancedere Position auch zu kriegen,
weil du eben was kannst,
was nicht jeder dahergelaufener Windows-Click-Admin kann,
mit Engagement alleine kommst du auch nicht weiter,
gibt, es gibt sicherlich,
genug, also,
wenn du keine Ahnung hast,
also, das sind die schlimmsten,
seriously,
die schlimmste Kombination an Leuten ist,
super motiviert,
und keine Ahnung,
das ist die allerschlimmste Kombination, die es gibt,
die machen viel, und machen nur Mist,
das ist quasi Geldverbrennungsmaschine schlechthin,
das ist die schlechteste Kombination an Leuten, die es gibt,
du musst wissen, was du machst,
du musst nicht alles wissen, das sage ich ja auch gar nicht,
und noch viel wichtiger,
für den persönlichen Karriere-Crime,
drüber reden, was du Tolles gemacht hast,
Vortrag,
oh,
Hex,
ist das irgendeine besondere Zahl?
Ne,
61.441 in Dezimal ist das,
aber danke schön für den Sub,
0xf001,
ich mache auch jetzt gleich agiles Bettke,
äh, genau, da wollte ich was zu sagen,
zählen für euch Bonuszahlungen,
Beteiligung, Weihnachtsgeld, Uhrjahrsgeld, zum Gehalt,
für eure Arbeitszeit,
als Beispiel, ihr habt einen Gehaltswunsch von
5000 und euch wird ein
Angebot von 4000
gemacht, aber es wird erwähnt, dass ihr im Durchschnitt auch
irgendwer
was, irgendwelche
sonstige Zahlen für die Gewünsche, würde das Angebot, ja
wenn das das ist, was ich haben will, ja, ja, würde ich machen
natürlich muss man immer ein bisschen
gucken, wie sich das zusammensetzt, also wenn die
das jetzt einfach nur sagen und am Ende
des Jahres entschieden wird, auch gibt kein Bonus, dann
natürlich nicht, Nico, Dankeschön für den
Sub, aber letztendlich ist
mir egal, wo die Kohle herkommt, solange es
am Ende des Jahres
unterm Strich dem entspricht, was ich haben will
wenn das jetzt alles nun
so super vage ist, dass es auch
heißen könnte, nee, gibt's nicht, dann nicht
ja, aber wenn du ein gewisses
Vertrauen darin hast und dass
die auch eine nachvollziehbare
History haben mit Bonuszahlungen
dass es die auch wirklich gibt, warum nicht
unterm Strich muss das rauskommen, was
du haben willst
also ich hab das auch so gemacht
ich hab im Vorstellungsgespräch
einfach mal
riesengroße Zahl gesagt
und da haben sie sich schon angeguckt
und haben gemeint, ah nee, ganz so viel ist es aber nicht
und haben sie aber gemeint, ja aber
Moment mal mit Rufbereitschaft
und Bonuszahlungen, dann sind
wir doch in dem Dreh
und Rufbereitschaft ist
ganz klar bei uns vertraglich
geregelt, was es dafür gibt und ist auch ganz
klar quasi
garantiert nicht, aber
ganz klar geplant, wie viele
Einheiten du davon quasi bekommst
im Jahr
kannst du ziemlich genau sagen
und die ziemlich gut im Vorfeld ausrechnen
Bonus ist auch die letzten Jahre
über relativ ähnlich immer gewesen
außer halt der persönliche, sogar der ist
aber relativ ähnlich und
das hat mir eingeleuchtet
da hab ich gesagt, ja okay, passt
ich hab absichtlich erstmal
richtig, was richtig hohes gesagt
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, was ich gesagt
hab, ich glaub ich hab gesagt 115.000
Euro und da haben sie
erstmal gesagt, das ist zu viel
und haben dann aber rumgerechnet mit Ruf
es geht um 5 Tage, nicht um 4 Tage Woche
5 Tage Woche, ist alles immer
auf 5 Tage Woche gerechnet
und haben gesagt, oh
es wäre ein bisschen viel
ja und dann haben sie mir
angefangen vorzurechnen, dass es aber
doch ganz gut, ganz gut passen
würde mit dem ganzen Bonus und Rufbereitschaft
Zulagen und so und das ist ja auch schon recht
fix und ja, da hab ich mich
dann drauf eingelassen und ich muss sagen
bis jetzt stimmt's
es ist sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr als das, was sie angekündigt haben
weil die haben fett Inflations
Dings, Ausgleich, Prämie, wie auch
immer man das nennt, Zulage bezahlt
ähm
es gibt
jetzt noch eine pauschale Zulage, dass
man überhaupt Rufbereitschaft macht
egal, ob man sie wirklich macht, allein schon, dass man
angerufen werden könnte, kriegt sie auch
mal eine extra Zulage
ich hab letztes Wochenende Rufbereitschaft gemacht
und das bringt
ein Wochenende Rufbereitschaft
geht bei uns von
Freitagabend so irgendwie 17
18 Uhr in dem Dreh, bis Montagmorgen
8 Uhr, das bringt
über 1000 Euro brutto
nochmal dazu
das wird, das ist wirklich
die halbe Lizenz zum Geldtrucken
die Rufbereitschaft dort
und das
also es hat sich bisher
alles das
bewahrheitet, was sie mir versprochen haben
im Vorstellungsgespräch, sogar noch
einen Ticken mehr, also
ich finde, wenn das unterm Strich stimmt
ist alles gut und bis jetzt
stimmt das, wie oft kommt es
zu Einsätzen, es kommt
öfters
ne, mach ich nicht
ich bin Senior Linux Engineer
also quasi im Prinzip
sowas wie Server Admin, nur dass es nicht
Server Admin heißt, ich komme aus
dem DevOps Bereich
allerdings
viele Server Admins nennen sich
einfach DevOps Engineer heute, weil es cooler klingt
ist aber trotzdem nicht 1 zu 1
das gleiche
ich mach hauptsächlich
aktuell Cloud-Infrastruktur
Kubernetes und Automatisierung im Cloud-Umfeld
ja, wie oft kommt es zu Einsätzen
es schwankt
es ist aber
so selten, dass ich immer noch finde, dass es sich lohnt
also
nehmen wir mal ein Negativbeispiel, ich hatte kurz vor Weihnachten ein
Wochenende Rufbereitschaft
da wurde ich
Samstag morgens angerufen, also ich hatte kurz vor Weihnachten ein Wochenende Rufbereitschaft, da wurde ich Samstag Morgens angerufen, da wurde ich Samstag Morgens angerufen, da wurde ich Samstag Morgens angerufen, da wurde ich Samstag Morgens angerufen, da wurde ich
dann muss ich auch wieder zurück, da war ich gerade draußen, wir haben eine Stunde, innerhalb von einer Stunde musste man am Rechner sein
und
dann habe ich mit dem was gebastelt, irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden lang
Samstag Morgens
und dann kam Sonntagnacht, das gleiche Wochenende
noch eine Monitoring Meldung, dass die Datenbank kaputt ist
da habe ich mich tatsächlich 4 Uhr Nachts eingeloggt
dann sogar
damals
und habe nachgeguckt
und war der Meinung, das ist ein Monitoring Fehler
Weil da stand, dass der Monitoring Agent nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich habe den Agent neu gestartet, bin in der Pen gegangen, bis ich dann Sonntagmittag nochmal nachgeguckt habe, weil ich mir gedacht habe, guckst du nochmal?
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, die Datenbank war tatsächlich kaputt.
Der Check war nur so suboptimal geschrieben, dass eine kaputte Datenbank das Monitoring zerstört.
Und ich sage, Datenbank ist nicht verfügbar.
Wird die Arbeitszeit noch extra vergütet oder ist die Pauschal weder noch, wenn du Einsatz hast und arbeitest, dann bekommst du Zeit gut geschrieben und kein Geld.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt schon öfters gehört, dass manche Leute sagen, wenn sie am Wochenende Einsatz haben von zwei Stunden, dann schreiben sie den Einsatz gar nicht auf, weil sie lieber die Kohle haben wollen dafür.
Ist gut, kann jeder machen, wie er will.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, wie das ist.
Müsste ich eigentlich wissen, weiß ich aber nicht.
Ist nicht, nee, ist sicherlich nicht legal.
Deswegen macht das ja auch keiner von uns.
Weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob das legal ist oder nicht legal ist.
Also die Einsatzzeit als Arbeitszeit, das ist sicherlich legal alles.
Ob es das nicht aufschreiben, legal ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn du, was?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Wieso, wenn du Einsatz hast, hast du keine Bereitschaft mehr, ist doch klar.
Wie bist du eigentlich ins Programmieren gekommen?
Oh, das ist jetzt zu lang die Story.
Erzähl dich nächsten Stream.
Hab ich sogar schon letztens mal erzählt.
Ach so.
Ähm.
Nee.
Da müsste ich mich ja leaken.
Und wo ich arbeite.
Das mache ich bestimmt nicht.
Irgendjemand hat doch eben gerade was mit zu hoch gefragt, oder?
Ja.
Denkst du, es lohnt sich da mit dem Lohn so eine richtig hohe Ansage zu machen, die eigentlich unrealistisch ist?
Lohnt sich.
Allerdings.
Du musst selbst nicht Dice of Cringe machen, wenn du es sagst.
Es muss quasi, es muss dir innerlich schon wehtun, ein bisschen, das zu sagen.
Aber du musst immer noch sagen können, okay, ich kann es, ich kann es aber trotzdem gerade so noch vertreten.
Dann ist es okay.
Ja, aber es lohnt sich.
Lohnt sich, klar.
Ja, nach der Ausbildung 100k, das wird wahrscheinlich jedem selbst einleuchten mit seinem, so sagen wir mal, innerlichen Cringe-Meter,
dass es halt nicht mehr im Bereich des, des nicht mal übertrieben hohen Realistischen ist, ja.
Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall immer eine große Zahl zu sagen.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch gar nichts sagen und fragen, was ist denn, was ist denn die Gehaltsspanne, weil das ist ja budgettechnisch sicherlich,
relativ, ne, wenn es ein größerer Laden ist, festgelegt.
Aber es, es schadet, es schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
Weil das, was ihr sagt, ist oftmals erstmal die grundsätzliche Verhandlungsbasis.
Bei mir lief es so, ich habe gesagt 115k, glaube ich zumindest.
Dass ich, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich 110, ich glaube ich habe 115.
110 habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich glaube ich habe 100, ich glaube ich habe nicht 120, ich habe 115 gesagt.
So, und...
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay, vielleicht busy viel.
Für das, was sie...
Aber, da haben sie gesagt, oh, ne, passt doch eigentlich mit den ganzen Zuschlägen.
Und insofern bin ich zufrieden jetzt.
Wie gesagt, auf 5 Tage, nicht auf 4 Tage.
Für 4 Tage kriege ich natürlich anteilmäßig 20% weniger.
Alles klar, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Bis die Tage.
Macht's gut, see you.